SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FOR ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BACKER FORGES BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORE TESTING BALLY DODD TORONTO
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HUESO HER TADO JONES
KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA LIMON
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN CONTROL OF BOTH HANDS.
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE REALM AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE. WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
CENTER MAN. AFTER WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR. INTERMENT GOD OF ALL
PEOPLE NATIONS AS WE CELEBRATE
MAY AS ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER OR AAPI
HERITAGE MONTH. WE PRAY IN
GRATITUDE FOR THE RICH
HISTORICAL AND CULTURAL
CONTRIBUTIONS OF INDIVIDUALS AND
GROUPS. OF SIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER DESCENT THE UNITED
STATES AND CALIFORNIA IN
PARTICULAR. WE PRAY FOR THOSE
WHO PREFER PERSEVERE TO CHIEF
FORMAL RECOGNITION FOR THEIR
HISTORICAL CONTRIBUTIONS IN
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES. WE
PRAY FOR THOSE WHO PERSEVERE
THROUGH GENERATIONS OF
XENOPHOBIA RACISM BIAS AND
VIOLENCE TO CONTRIBUTE THEIR
SKILLS AND TALENTS IN AREAS OF
SCIENCE AND MEDICINE. LITERATURE
AND ART GOVERNMENT AND LAW. WE
PRAY FOR THOSE WHO CONTINUE
TODAY TO ENRICH THE DIVERSITY OF
THIS LAND. SO THAT TOGETHER WE
CAN CELEBRATE AND LEARN FROM
EACH OTHER AND THE SPIRIT OF
PARTNERSHIP AND COLLABORATION
FOR THE COMMON GOOD. WE ASK THIS
IN YOUR NAME. I'M IN. OUR JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BUT HE'S A CENTERMAN OR- YOU'LL
START SO THERE WINNER MEDIAN
APPROACH. AND SAN. YEAH A LITTLE. THANK YOU MEMBERS. WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO THE PRIVILEGES OF
FLOOR. MEMBERS YOUR INITIATIVES
TAKEN COMMENTS OFF THE FLOOR
CONVERSATIONS NOW WE'RE GOING TO
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR SOON
CENTER I'M BURKE FOR WHAT
PURPOSE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE UNDER PRIVILEGES OF FLOOR-
IN IS HERE THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TOO WELCOME THE NEWEST
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BAR CENTER DAY MEN. SAW. WELL
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO'VE BEEN
TAKING LEGAL ADVICE FROM SENATOR
MEN HE IS EFFECTIVE FRIDAY THANK
TO FRIDAY'S ACTUALLY AUTHORIZED
TO GIVE IT SO. CONGRADULATIONS
INNER MEN. UNDER PROVISION FLOOR
CENTER MEANT. A HUNDRED READING
ASSIGNMENTS AND- ART MEMBERS
REMOVING HIS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGE FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. NOW TO
MOTIONS RATHER RESOLUTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF MAY.
TWO TWO FIVE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK. THEREFORE
MOMENTS AT THE TEST THEY WILL BE
DEEMED ADOPTED. NOW MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE'RE MOVING NOW TO THE SECOND
READING FILE CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL. ELEVEN THIRTY
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX OF AMENDMENTS TEN
SEVENTY FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS
TWELVE FORTY SIX WITH AMENDMENTS
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS TWELVE NINETY WITH
AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN FORTY WITH
AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
EIGHT SIXTY SIX. ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT SECOND REMOVED GREEN
DOING READ. NOW WE'RE MOVING TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. WE HAVE
THREE CENTER BATES ARE YOU
PREPARED. YES SIR SHE IS MOUNT
SECTOR. ME SENATE CENTER BATES.
FILE A NUMBER OF FIRE FILE I'M
TWENTY ONE FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF JULIA
LOPEZ INYOUR MEAT LET OUR
RODRIGUEZ FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BOARD OF TRUSTEES MISS LOPEZ OF
THE PAST PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF COLLEGE
FUTURES FOUNDATION IN MISS
RODRIGUEZ IF THE NATIONAL
TRAINER FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY'S
YOUTH LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE. THEY
WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MAY FOURTH ON A
FIVE ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENT. NINETY NINE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FALLING TWENTY ONE. ALLEN
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER FIVE FOR JUST AYE
BRADFORD AYE CABRERA AYE
PROTECTING. I DALY DOT FIVE
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG I
WESTERN. HI FURTADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA I
LIMON I MCGUIRE FIVE MELENDEZ.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A SHOW
A VOTE I PAN. PORTANTINO I ROTH
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
I BY CASTING AYE WIENER I WILL.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. ALLEN VALLEY GROWTH
MELENDEZ HAM ROTH. STERN WILK.
THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED NOW
MOVING ON THE FALL ITEM TWENTY
TWO CENTER BATES. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF CLEAR RAMSEY AS CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR DISABILITY ADULTS
AND HOUSING INTEGRATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES PRIOR TO THIS ROLE
MISTER RAMSAY WAS A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR JUSTICE IN AGING
SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE. ON MAY FOURTH
ON THE UNANIMOUS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
HEARING SEEN NINE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AND
I FACE I BAKER I PORCHES I
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CORTES I DALY. DODD FIVE
DURACELL AYE EGGMAN AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL AYE FURTADO
AYE JONES HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED
I LEYVA HI LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S AYE BEEN. I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH. I PAN
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN NUMBER FIVE LAKE
COUNTY I WIENER I WILK. PLEASE
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN DALY
GROVE PAN RALPH STERN WILK ICE
THIRTY THREE KNOWS ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED NOW
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE SENATOR BATES THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF THE FOLLOWING APPOINTEES TO
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
CAROLINE OUT ALVAREZ DR CHARLES
NIECE IN LEONARDO RODRIGUEZ ON
THE COMMISSION MISS OPERAS AND
MISTER RODRIGUEZ ARE STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVES AND DOCTOR NEEDS
REPRESENTS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA THESE APPOINTEES WERE
APPROVED IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MAY FOURTH ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR- VOTE. FOR THE DISCUSSION
OF THE VERY. ANY FOR QUESTIONS.
NONESECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BACKER. AYE FORTUS
AYE BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
PROTESTING AYE DALY. DODD. FIVE
ZERO SEVEN FIVE EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ FIVE GROW.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI FURTADO
HI JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA HI LIMÓN I MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN AYE A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN
. PORTANTINO I ROTH RUBIO HI
SKINNER I STERN. AMBERG HI MY
CASTING I WIENER AYE WILK. HIGHS
THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO THE
SENATE THIRD READING OUR FIRST
ITEM UP IS FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX
INTER OCULAR YOU PREPARED. HE IS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA RELATIVE TO
TARDIVE DYSKINESIA AWARENESS DAY
SKINNER ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON FELLOW
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY SEVEN IN
AN EFFORT TO RISE. AWARENESS OF
HARD DRIVE DYSKINESIA AS YOU
KNOW MAY IS MENTAL HEALTH MONTH
AS WELL AS SO MANY OTHERS AN
IMPORTANT TIME TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE ONE IN FIVE U. S. ADULTS
LIVING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS. MANY
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS CHRONIC
MENTAL ILLNESS REQUIRE TREATMENT
WITH MEDICATIONS THAT CAN BE
HARMFUL YET HELPFUL AND EVEN.
ALTER THEIR LIVING STYLE THAT IT
IS SO DESPERATELY TRYING TO
ADHERE TO IN OUR SOCIETY. BUT
CAN ALSO LEAD TO TAR DIVE
DYSKINESIA PART I'VE DYSKINESIA
IS A MOMENT THE MOVEMENT RATHER
A MOVEMENT DISORDER. THAT IS
CHARACTERIZED BY RANDOM
INVOLUNTARY UNCONTROLLED
MOVEMENTS OF DIFFERENT MUSCLES
THROUGHOUT THE PERSON'S BODY IT
AFFECTS THE MUSCLES ASSOCIATED
WITH WALKING SPEECH EATING EVEN%
BREATHING IT CAN DEVELOP MONTHS
AND YEARS. DECADES LATER AFTER
THESE MEDICATIONS ARE NO LONGER
BEING USED AND DISCONTINUE NOT
EVERYONE DEVELOPS CARD I
DYSKINESIA BUT IT CAN BE
DEVELOPED BUT IT VERB VERY OFTEN
IT IS PERMANENT. PATIENTS
SUFFERING FROM PART I'VE
DYSKINESIA OFTEN SUFFER
EMBARRASSMENT LEADING TO
FEELINGS OF ISOLATION WITHDRAWAL
AND- LACK OF FAMILY
PARTICIPATION. THE MORE WE CAN
RAISE AWARENESS OF THIS ILLNESS
THE MORE WE CAN MOVE IN THE
NEGATIVE STIGMA ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT CARD I'VE DYSKINESIAS OFTEN
UNRECOGNIZED AND PATIENTS
SUFFERING FROM THE ILLNESS ARE
COMMONLY MIS DIæN MISDIAGNOSED
BUT THERE IS SOME HOPE. AFTER
SEVERAL YEARS OF RESEARCH THE
FDA HAS APPROVED MEDICATIONS
MEANT TO TREAT GARDAI DYSKINESIA
PROVIDING RELIEF TO THOSE WHO
HAVE SUFFERED FROM THIS ILLNESS
WE CAN ONLY HOPE THAT THE MORE
WE EDUCATE PEOPLE ABOUT THE
ILLNESS AND THE DISEASE THE MORE
WE CAN FIND WAYS TO CURE IT. FOR
THESE REASONS AND MORE I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT SR SIXTY SEVEN AND
JOINED WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
MULLIN GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND IN
SUPPORTING THOSE AFFECTED BY
PART DIVE DYSKINESIA. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS I DON'T ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS VERY ON THIS
ITEM HERE NINETEEN NINE. MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX. NINETY
NINE ALL EYES THIRTY THREE.
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA CHANGE
THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE THE FILE
ITEM FIFTY NINE. SENATOR MEN.
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY BY SENATOR MEN
RELATIVE TO ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH
CENTERMAN THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ON
BEHALF OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I AM PROUD TO PRESENT S.
R. EIGHTY WHICH RECOGNIZES MAY
AS A P. I A HERITAGE MONTHS EACH
MAY OUR COUNTRY CELEBRATES THE
DIVERSITY OF PEOPLE WHOSE
FAMILIES IMMIGRATED FROM ASIA
AND THE PACIFIC ISLANDS TO COME
TO AMERICA FOR OPPORTUNITY AND
FREEDOM. THE MONTH WAS INITIALLY
CHOSEN TO COMMEMORATE THE
IMMIGRATION OF THE FIRST
RECORDED JAPANESE IMMIGRANTS THE
UNITED STATES. ON MAY SEVENTH
EIGHTEEN FORTY THREE AS WELL AS
THE COMPLETION OF THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD ON MAY
TENTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE. TODAY
THE API COMMUNITY IS THE FASTEST
GROWING ETHNIC GROUP IN THE
UNITED STATES. WITH MORE THAN
SIX MILLION ASIAN AMERICANS
CALLING CALIFORNIA HOME. OVER
HALF OF THE API'S IN
CALIFORNIA'S ARE IMMIGRANTS LIKE
MY PARENTS WHAT OTHER API
FAMILIES HAVE LIVED IN AMERICA
FOR GENERATION. AS AMERICANS WE
BRING A DIVERSITY OF RICH
CULTURAL HERITAGE THIS TO
IMPROVE OUR COUNTRY AND THIS
MONTH IS A CELEBRATION AND
RECOGNITION OF OUR VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES. SINCE THE EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS API COMMUNITIES HAVE
MADE MAJOR CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STATE AND NATION WE BUILT
RAILROADS AND LEVEES FARM FIELDS
CARED FOR THE SICK BUILT SMALL
BUSINESSES TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS AND
UNIVERSITIES. AND FOUGHT FOR
AMERICA. WE ALSO PROVIDE
EXCELLENT ENTERTAINMENT ON EACH
YEAR DESKS IS THE BOOK RISE A
PROP A POP HISTORY OF ASIAN
ASIAN AMERICA FROM NINETIES TO
NOW. WE HPE YOU ENJOY THIS BOOK
IS A TAKES ON A FUN THOUGHTFUL
AND BEAUTIFUL VENTURE ON HOW API
CULTURE CAME TO BE WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT IS TODAY. IS A STRONGER AND
BETTER COUNTRY BECAUSE OF ASIAN
AMERICANS AND NATIVE HAWAIIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS WE'RE
PROUD TO BE ASIANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS AND ASK THAT YOU JOIN
US IN CELEBRATING API A HISTORY
HERITAGE MONTH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR ALSO
. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- AS
CHAIR OF THE LATINO CAUCUS AND
AS A SENATOR REPRESENTING A VERY
DIVERSE- API COULD OUR COMMUNITY
INCLUDING THAI TOWN KOREATOWN
HISTORIC FILIPINO TOWN CHINATOWN
A LITTLE TOKYO IS MY HONOR TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF S. R. EIGHTY
. OF COURSE UNDERSTANDING OUR
PAST AND THAT KNOWLEDGE IN
HEROES AND I DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
OF STRENGTHENS OUR RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN EVERY RESIDENT OF THE
STATE. ALTHOUGH THE API
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN FRAUGHT WITH
BOUTS OF DISCRIMINATION POLICY
DECISIONS THAT TOP TARGETED THEM
FOR UNSEEMLY BEING DIFFERENT.
THEY HAVE MANY MANY OTHER
STORIES TO TELL. FROM THE
CHINESEEXCLUSION ACT THAT
RESTRICTED CHINESE EMIGRATION IN
THE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS AND MADE
THEM INELIGIBLE FOR
NATURALIZATION. TO THEN TURN MEN
OF JAPANESE AMERICANS GENERAL
DURING WORLD WAR TWO WHERE THEIR
HARD EARNED POSSESSIONS HOMES
AND BUSINESSES WERE TAKEN AWAY.
TO THE STRUGGLE THE LEADERSHIP
OF FILIPINO LEADERS INCLUDING
LARRY YOUR LONG THAT SPOT AND
SPURRED THE DELANO GATE GREAT
BOY STRIKE. WHICH SAYS OUR JOB
IS ULTIMATELY JOINED AND LED THE
FORMATION OF THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS UNION THE API AND THE
LATINO COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
INTRINSICALLY LINKED THROUGHOUT
OUR HISTORY AND OUR CONSTANT
STRUGGLES FOR HUMAN RIGHTS. API
OUR RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN KEY TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR NATION
BUILDING THE TRANSCONTINENTAL
RAILROAD AND ADVOCATING FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS I JOIN ENORMOUS
INNOVATION AND OUR LEADERS
GLOBALLY. WE ARE HOME IN
CALIFORNIA TO SIX POINT THREE
MILLION API AMERICANS ON THE
IMPACT OF API BUSINESS OWNERS
CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED. DESPITE
THE SUCCESS AS THEY CONTINUE TO
FACE DISCRIMINATION PREJUDICE
AND HATE WE MUST BE CONSTANTLY
VIGILANT THANK YOU TO THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING S. R. EIGHTY.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF EIGHT. HIS
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF S. R.
EIGHTY. I'M AS OUR AUTHOR STATED
. THE API COMMUNITY IS THE
FASTEST GROWING IN THE US RIGHT
NOW AND IN CALIFORNIA END OF THE
TWENTY TWO MILLION EIGHT P. I.
INDIVIDUALS IN THE U. S. ONE
THIRD LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. NOW
WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY THERE ARE.
MANY MANY MANY DIFFERENT
NATIONALITIES ETHNICITIES AND
LANGUAGES MORE THAN NINETEEN AND
EACH HAS THEIR OWN CULTURE THEIR
OWN IMMIGRATION HISTORY THEIR
OWN IDENTITIES. AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOR API WOMEN
THEIR STRUGGLES VERY. SO IT WILL
LIKE ALL WOMEN UNFORTUNATELY IN
OUR CULTURE ECONOMICALLY THEY
MAKE LESS HOWEVER DEPENDING ON
WHERE THEY THEIR FAMILIES OR
THEY ORIGINALLY CAME FROM THEY
MAKE EVEN FAR LESS SO FOR
EXAMPLE. CERTAIN OF OUR- API
COMMUNITY WOMEN. MAKE VIETNAMESE
CAMBODIAN THAI OTHERS MAKE HALF
OF WHAT THE AAPI COMMUNITY WHO
ARE FROM INDIA CHINA AND SOME OF
THE OTHER COUNTRIES. AND THESE
DIFFERENCES CONTINUE TO THE
VARYING LEVELS OF ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE TO EDUCATION TO
CHILDCARE TO CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES AND MORE. AND I
POINT THIS OUT BECAUSE IT P. I.
COMMUNITIES IS NOT A MONOLITH.
BUT THE VIOLENCE AND THE BIAS
AGAINST IT IS. MONOLITHIC IN IS
NOT DISTINGUISH SO WE SAW
VIOLENCE AGAINST THE API
COMMUNITY RISE AND ALARMING
RATES DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
ESPECIALLY TOWARDS API WOMEN AND
IT IS AN EXCUSABLE. THE
FATHERING OF OUR API BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IS DANGEROUS AND
UNWARRANTED SO LET US CELEBRATE
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF API'S IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO LET US WORK
TO GET THE ECONOMIC JUSTICE FOR
ALL WOMEN BUT ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
WOMEN. IN OUR DIFFERENT- ARE BY
PARK COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. IN
ORDER. CENTER WINNER. I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR LGBTQ
CAUCUS AND SOLIDARITY- WITH OUR
API COMMUNITY I HAVE THE HONOR
OF REPRESENTING A DISTRICT THAT
IT- IS NEARLY FORTY PERCENT-
API- VERY DIVERSE- IN A VERY
VIBRANT COMMUNITY AND ALSO A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS BEEN THAT
HELP CREATE OUR COMMUNITY HELPED
CREATE SAN FRANCISCO HOPE CREEK
CALIFORNIA BUT IS UNDER SO MUCH
PRESSURE- RIGHT NOW WITH
ESCALATING VIOLENCE ON FOR AS
LONG AS I HAVE LIVED IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS-
HI WE HAVE SEEN. A TAX ON
CHINESE ELDERS IN CHINATOWN
PEOPLE COMING INTO CHINATOWN
THINKING THAT IT'S OKAY TO PICK
ON A COMMUNITY TO ATTACK- TO
HARM SENIORS IN THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THEY VIEW THE COMMUNITY
I SOMEHOW WEEK AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE ALL THESE TOXIC
STEREOTYPES AROUND- ABOUT API
PEOPLE- AND IS IT IS SO
DESTRUCTIVE AND IT'S SO FALSE
AND SLANDERS AND THE VIOLENCE
NEED TO STOP- AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE. ON OUR
NEIGHBORS BACKS. SO I URGE AND I
BOTH. THANK YOU SENATOR WARNER
CENTER NIELSEN. MR PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE SENATE
I HAVE SPEAK WITH A WITH A FULL
HEART. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION. A LITTLE LATER I
HAVE A BILL OF MY OWN A VERY. A
LARGE NUMBER OF CO AUTHORSHIP
WILL DO SOME MORE TO RECOGNIZE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
CONTRIBUTIONS. DEVINDRA NORMA'S
DATING EVEN BEFORE THE GOLD RUSH
THE PARTICULARLY EXCEL RATING
THEREAFTER. GREAT BOOK. TALKS
ABOUT THE SEARCH FOR GOLD
MOUNTAIN. AND THAT ETHNOLOGISTS
. THE ASIAN PARTICULARLY CHINESE
WHO CAME TO AMERICA TO BUILD THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD. TO
OPEN CALIFORNIA. TO ALL THE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES. THE
POPULATION. WHO WOULD COME HERE
. ONE OF THE MOSTSIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE HISTORY OF
THE STATE. THEY REMAINED HERE.
AND AFTER THE WARS OF SOUTHEAST
ASIA. RECENTLY HUNDRED OF
THOUSANDS LEFT THOSE COUNTRIES
AND CAME AND SETTLED HERE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. BUT
PARTICULARLY IN THE VALLEYS THE
SACRAMENTO AND THE SAN JOAQUIN.
AND WE WELCOME THEM. AND THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS AGAIN TO OUR STATE
. THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN A STEADY
SOURCE. OF MEMORIZATION.
ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
DEVELOPMENT OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS
WELL THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THEM
WITH SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION
THEN I THANK YOU FOR THAT
SUPPORT. INTERNAL SENSE INTERCOM
WATER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
WANT TO RISE AS VICE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF S. R.
EIGHTY. AND ACCENTUATE A NUMBER
OF THE COMMENTS MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUES. HOW ROBUST AND
VIBRANT AND DIVERSE THE EIGHT
API COMMUNITY IS. I KNOW THAT
SOME. WOULD LIKE TO CONSIDER THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND THE EIGHTY P. I
COMMUNITY AS ONE THAT IS MAYBE
ROBUST AND FRAUGHT WITH CONFLICT
. I LIKE TO FOCUS ON THE
SIMILARITIES. SIMILAR TO THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY WE
KNOW THAT OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS FROM THE AAPI COMMUNITY
HAVE A HISTORY THAT IS FILLED
WITH INCREDIBLE STORIESOF
RESISTANCE PERSISTENCE. AND
DETERMINATION TO FIGHT FOR BASIC
HUMAN RIGHTS WE ALSO KNOW. THAT
COMMON GROUND HAS BEEN FOUND IN
THE FIGHT AGAINST WHITE
SUPREMACY. AND WANTING TO PICK
APART COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WANTING TO DIVIDE AND STOKE FEAR
WITHIN THE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE DONE THAT WE HAVE
SEEN ESPECIALLY IN LOS ANGELES
AND MY DISTRICT I KNOW AND ALSO
IN YOUR DISTRICT AS WELL SENATOR
BRADFORD. IS BUILDING COMMUNITY
TIES FOCUSING AROUND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND FAITH BASED
COMMUNITIES TO REALLY UP LEFT
THE SIMILARITIES IN OUR HISTORY
AND OUR COMMON STRUGGLE TO BE
SEEN AND VALUED IN THIS COUNTRY.
I BELIEVE THAT THAT IS WHAT IS
INHERENT IN S. R. EIGHTY WHICH
IS WHY ONCE AGAIN AS VICE CHAIR
OF THE LOOK CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
IN SUPPORT. OF S. R. EIGHTY.
THANK YOU CENTER WHITE CULTURE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I THINK
THAT'S TENTH SENATE DISTRICT HAS
54% THE POPULATION IS PACIFIC
ASIAN ISLAND THAT'S THAT PART OF
THAT'S WHAT THE BAY FROM HEY
WE'RE DOWN TO SANTA CLARA AND I
REMEMBER IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WHEN I WASAN INTERN IN
WASHINGTON DC FRANK WHARTON OF
NEW YORK INTRODUCED HOUSE JOINT
RESOLUTION FIFTY FOUR- WHICH
WAS. MAKE A COMMEMORATIVE MONTH
ASIAN PACIFIC HERITAGE MONTH IS
NINETY IS NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. DANIEL ANYWAY IN THE
HAWAIIAN OF THE SENATOR FROM
HAWAII INTRODUCED A SIMILAR
RESOLUTION IN THE SENATE AND
NEITHER THE BILL'S PASSED NINE
BILLS PASSED THROUGH IN SEVENTY
EIGHT POURTANT CAME BACK AND HE
INTRODUCED- HOUSE JOINT
RESOLUTION AT THOUSAND SEVEN AND
THAT JUST PROPOSED THAT THE
PRESIDENT WOULD PER CALL
PROCLAIM A WEEK WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE THE SEVENTH AND TENTH OF
THE MONTH DURING THE FIRST TEN
DAYS OF MAY NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE AS- ASIAN PACIFIC AMERICAN
HERITAGE WEEK TWO IS JUST A ONE
TIME ONE WEEK PROCLAMATION. AND
THAT PASSED THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE AND WAS SIGNED BY JIMMY
CARTER BECAME LAW AND THEN AFTER
THAT THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE WAS
AMENDED EACH YEAR TO HAVE THE.
SEVEN DAY PERIOD IN MAY. TO
RECOGNIZED AS ASIAN PACIFIC WEEK
AND THAT HAPPENED FOR A DECADE
AND IN FIVE AND THE PRESIDENT'S
DID THESE PROCLAMATIONS AND DID
THAT AND THEN FINALLY AS WE
HEARD FROM- ARE CALLING IN
NINETEEN NINETY IT BECAME. A
RESOLUTION WAS INTRODUCED TO
EXPAND IT TO OBSERVE OBSERVE A
WEEK AND A NOW ANNUALLY WE'VE
DESIGNATED THIS ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN HERITAGE WEEK SO EVEN
GIVEN ALL THE STRUGGLES THE API
CAR- COMMUNITIES HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA EVEN GETTING THIS
PROCLAMATION FOR. A MONTH TOOK A
LONG TIME IT WAS NEVER EASY SO I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF THE VERY
ON THE SIDE OF. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF THE BRAIN HEARING
CHAIN NINE SOONER MEN WHICH LIKE
TO CLOSE I LIKE TO THINK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IN YOUR ALLY SHIP- IN
FIGHTING ANTI ASIAN HATE WHICH
IS OBVIOUSLY A PRESSING ISSUE OF
OUR TIME. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE ITEM
FIFTY NINE. HEARING C. NINE ICE
THIRTY THREE KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW I'M GONNA
CENTER MEANT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT UNDER CHECK PRODUCES A
FLOOR I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR
API A HERITAGE MONTH HONOREES.
YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR KIND AND
INSPIRING WORDS IN SUPPORT OF S.
R. EIGHTY I ALSO WANT TO THANK
DR RICHARD PAN FOR ALL OF HIS
HARD WORK- DOCTOR PAN THE CHAIR
OF THE API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS-
THE OTHER MEMBER OF THE API
CAUCUS HERE IN THE SENATE. ONE
PERSON COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY
BUT WHOSE HARD WORK MADE THIS
POSSIBLE. AS PART OF OUR API A
HERITAGE MONTH CELEBRATIONS THE
CALIFORNIA AAPI LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS RECOGNIZES DISTINGUISHED
API LEADERS AND HONORS THEM WITH
EXCELLENCE AWARDS. THIS YEAR
WE'RE PROUD TO RECOGNIZE EIGHT
HONOREES WHO GIVE US HOPE SALAS
AND COURAGE IN TIMES SUCH AS
THESE WHEN WE NEED IT MOST. EACH
HONOREE ENRICHES OUR HISTORY AND
CULTURE THROUGH THEIR TREATMENTS
IN DIFFERENT WAYS SO I NOW LIKE
TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
GALLERY AS WE CELEBRATE OUR
FOLLOWING HONOREES. FOR
EXCELLENCE IN ADVOCACY WE HONOR
TAMMY JO HE'S THE CO FOUNDER AND
CEO OF HATE IS A VIRUS. AND FEAR
TRIED TO WIN KEEP THROWS UP
PUSHES BACK AND GIVES PEOPLE THE
COURAGE TO FIGHT AGAINST
INJUSTICE. MISTER HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED AS NBC ASIAN
AMERICANS A THROUGH THE RISING
STAR GEORGETOWN ENTREPRENEUR OF
THE YEAR AND A POWER WOMAN IN DC
TECH. SHE'S A LEADER THAT FIND A
CURE FOR HATE WITH HER TODAY AS
WELL AS HER HUSBAND AND HER HEAD
IS A VIRUS CO FOUNDER AND VP OF
DEVELOPMENT.
FOR EXCELLENCE IN ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT WE- HONOR DR CAN
JOHN. HE IS AN ACTOR PRODUCER
AND WRITER AND YES A MEDICAL
DOCTOR THAT MANY KNOWS MISTER
CHOW FROM THE HANGOVER
FRANCHISE. SEND YOUR CHIANG FROM
THE HIT TV SHOW ONE OF MY
FAVORITES COMMUNITY. AND MR GO
FROM THE BLOCKBUSTER FILM CRAZY
RICH ASIANS. OTHERS LIKE MY
DAUGHTER ANDERSON- KNOW HIM
PRIMARILY AS HIMSELF FROM HIS
INCREDIBLY ENTERTAINING
COMMENTARY ON THE MASK SINGER
AND I CAN SEE YOUR VOICE. BEHIND
THE STAGE THOUGH DR JOHN HAS
BEEN A ADVOCATE FOR CHANGE. AND
IS FOUGHT AGAINST THE RISE IN
ANTI ASIAN HATE A LEADING
ADVOCATE. LAST YEAR HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS PASSED THE
HISTORIC API EQUITY BUDGET.
WHICH DELIVERED KEY RESOURCES TO
THE API COMMUNITY TO COMBAT THE
RISE IN ANTI ASIAN HATE
INCIDENTS. THANK YOU DOCTOR FROM. FOR EXCELLENCE IN BUSINESS WE
HONOR DR CHARLES LONG. AS SAY
CAPITALS UP THE SOCCER CAPITAL
INC'S FOUNDER AND CHAIRMAN. DR
FONG IS HAS BECOME A GLOBAL
BUSINESSMAN AND PHILANTHROPIST.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE DR
WONG FOUNDED THE TRIALS ONE
FOUNDATIONS WITH A MISSION TO
BOLSTER ENABLE AND INSPIRE
GLOBAL DEVELOPMENT IN EDUCATION
HEALTH AND INNOVATION. JOINING
DOCTOR WONG TODAY ARE HIS
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU DOCTOR. FOR
EXCELLENCE IN CIVIL RIGHTS AND
PUBLIC SERVICES WE HONOR
MANIFESTO LIGA AND ALIGNING I'M
AND I'M MISPRONOUNCING THAT
NAMED I APOLOGIZE I SIMONE
ACTIVISTS REVOLUTIONARY LEADER
AND VISIONARY WHOSE
REPRESENTATION HAS OPENED DOORS
FOR THE PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY. BOTH NEAR HER AREA
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE. HE'S
CURRENTLY SERVING HER THIRD TERM
ON THE JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT GOVERNING BOARD
IN DALY CITY WHERE SHE GARNERED
THE HIGHEST VOTE IN THE HISTORY
OF THIS DISTRICTS ELECTION- IF
YOU HAVE I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
MEETING HER EARLIER TODAY AND-
YOU CAN DEFINITELY FEEL THE LOVE
SHE HAS FOR HER COMMUNITY. AND
HER PASSION AND LOOK OUT SHE'S
GOT GREAT THINGS AHEAD OF HER AS
WELL. SPEAKING OF LOVE. WHOLE
FAMILIES ABLE TO JOIN HER DANGER
ON THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR
EXCELLENCE IN HEALTH WE HAVE
ANOTHER DOCTOR WE'RE HONORING
UROLOGIST AND KIDNEY TRANSPLANT
SURGEON DR PETER PRETEND. DOCTOR
TEN WASN'T CMA'S FIRST FILIPINO
AMERICAN PRESIDENT AND THE FIRST
TO SERVE TWO TERMS. HE'S BEEN A
LEADER IN PROTECTING AND
EXPANDING UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. HE IS THE FOUNDER OF
LIFE PLAN INTERNATIONAL WHICH
FURNISHES LIFESAVING TRANSPLANTS
IN DEVELOPING COUNTRIES. PLEASE
WELCOME DOCTOR MONTANA'S WIFE
MELANIE. FOR EXCELLENCE IN LABOR
WE HONOR SOMEONE THAT MANY IN
THIS BUILDING OTE- BRYAN HONG.
BRIAN IS OF COURSE ONE OF THE
NICEST PEOPLE YOU'LL EVER MEET
AND IS NO STRANGER TO THIS
BUILDING. S A LONG HISTORY OF
FIGHTING FOR CALIFORNIA'S
HARDEST WORKERS AND IS CURRENTLY
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION. PRIOR TO
JOINING CFA MISTER HALL WAS A
SUCCESSFUL ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS. AND UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA. OF COURSE BRIAN HAS
TO HAVE AN ENTOURAGE ANYWHERE HE
GOES AND SO JOIN HIM TODAY HE
HAS HIS GIRLFRIEND MIA. ME ALONG
WITH HIS CFA COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING CF IS GENERAL MANAGER
TYRONE HENDRIX WELCOME AND
CONGRATULATIONS. FOR EXCELLENCE
IN SCIENCE WE AVE THE VERY
PRECOCIOUS ENVIRONMENT TO WHO IS
A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD TECH
ENTREPRENEUR SAM PROMOTER AND
GENDER EQUALITY ACTIVIST. LAST
MONTH HER NEWEST AND LATEST OF
SEVERAL MEDICAL RESEARCH PROJECT
WORKING ON PRECISION MEDICINE IN
OVARIAN CANCER USING NEW MACHINE
LEARNING TECHNOLOGIES PLACED
FIRST IN ALL OF CALIFORNIA AT
THE CALIFORNIA SCIENCES AND IN
ENGINEERING FAIR. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU GUYS WERE DOING YOUR
FOURTEEN BUT- NOT THIS. SHE'S
GOT. I HAVE A LOT OF DREAMS AND
AMBITIONS INCLUDING BECOMING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IN APPROXIMATELY TWENTY ONE OR
TWENTY TWO YEARS- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO POSSIBLY CALLING HERMADAM PRESIDENT AND I AM SURE
HER FAMILY WHOSE WITH HER TODAY
IS INCREDIBLY PROUD OF HER- OUR
CONGRATULATIONS. MISTRETTA. OUR
FINAL HONOREE THAT I KNOW MANY
OF YOU ARE EXCITED TO MEET
UNFORTUNATE CAN JOIN US TODAY
BECAUSE IS A HOME GAME TONIGHT-
BUT WE ARE HONORED TO RECOGNIZE-
SHOWTIME SHOHEI OHTANI FOR
EXCELLENCE IN SPORTS. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SHOHEI OHTANI
SIGNED WITH THE LOS ANGELES
ANGELS MY HOMETOWN TEAM.
BRINGING THE JAPANESE TWO WAY
SUPERSTAR MLB. HIS IMPACT ON
BASEBALL WAS IMMEDIATELY
IMMEDIATE AND QUICKLY RESHAPED
THE WAY THAT FANS AND
ORGANIZATIONS YOU THE GAME OF
BASEBALL. SINCE HIS MAJOR LEAGUE
DEBUT MISTER CONNIE HAS GONE ON
TO BE NAMED THE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE AMERICAN LEAGUE MOST
VALUABLE PLAYER. THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AMERICAN
LEAGUE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR. A
LOUISVILLE SILVER SLUGGER
RECIPIENT. AND THE FIRST ALL
STAR TO BE SELECTED AS BOTH A
PITCHER AND POSITION PLAYER TO A
PLAYER. MANY FANS OF BASEBALL
INCLUDING MYSELF THINK HE IS THE
MOST EXCITING PLAYER OF OUR
LIFETIMES- SO- GIVE IT UP FOR
MISTER SHOHEI OHTANI WHO CANNOT
BE HERE. NOW WE CANNOT THANK
EACH OF OUR HONOREES ENOUGH FOR
ELEVATING API VOICES AND
INSISTING THAT OUR COMMUNITY
VISIBLE HEARD- YOU MAKE US ALL
PROUD CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS. PLEASE GIVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
SAY CONGRATULATIONS AND WELCOME
. HAPPY API MONTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEN FOR THAT
NOW WE'RE MOVING BACK TO THE
DAILY FILE WERE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FORTY CENTER HER TADO
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY ONE
BY SENATOR HER TADO RELATIVE TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES CENTER A
TODDLE. THANK YOU TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT S. C. R. NINETY ONE
WHICH DESIGNATES MAY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
INCLUSION MONTH. RECOGNIZING
THAT ALL PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF
DISABILITY STATUS DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY BE FULLY INCLUDED IN
COMMUNITY LIFE IN CALIFORNIA. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE THE
LETTERMAN DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SERVICES ACT PROP
FORTH A NEW ERA OF SERVICES.
BASED ON THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SHOULD RECEIVE SERVICES THAT
ENABLE THEM TO LIVE SELF
DIRECTED LIVES IN COMMUNITIES OF
THEIR CHOOSING. OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW BEST TO
MEET THE SCHOOL HAS CONTINUED TO
EVOLVE AND IMPROVE. AS
INSTITUTIONAL CARE HAS LARGELY
BEEN REPLACED BY HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. A
GROWING NUMBER OF FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER
WITH THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY OVER THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
CURRENTLY RECEIVE SERVICES.
THROUGH THE LETTERMAN ACT. WHICH
SUPPORTS CHILDREN LIVING IN THE
FAMILY HOME AND PROMOTES
INDEPENDENT LIFE FOR ADULTS.
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ARE OUR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS NEIGHBORS COWORKERS.
CLASSMATES AND FRIENDS THEY
SHOULD BE WELCOMED AND INTO ALL
PARTS OF COMMUNITY LIFE. THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS
NOT ENOUGH TO MERELY A SEPT THE
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SERVED BY OUR REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM. IT IS TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO FRAME THIS
CONVERSATION AS A ONE OF
INCLUSION. S. R. NINETY ONE
RECOGNIZES THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. CAN AND SHOULD
MAKE DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES
WITH AS MUCH OR AS LITTLE
SUPPORT AS NEEDED. THIS
RESOLUTION CELEBRATES THE
INDIVIDUALS GROUPS AND ADVOCATES
WHO HAVE RAISED AWARENESS OF
INDIVIDUALS. WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS AND CONTRIBUTIONS. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ADD WE WILL BE
AMENDED IN. BUT THIS RESOLUTION
ON THE ASSEMBLY TO INCLUDE THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR THE
RATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF.
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON A FILE ITEM FORTY. ALLEN
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER FIVE FORGES. I
CORTESE AYE DALY DODD. FIVE
TORONTO FIVE EGGMAN AYE GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE HERTZBERG
BY WESTERN HI FURTADO. I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA I
LIMÓN I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN
AYE OTOBO AYE PAN. PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH. RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN NUMBER HI MY CASTING HI
WIENER AYE WILK. ALL EYES THIRTY
THREE KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN.
SENATOR BURKE HE'S PREPARED
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
HUNDRED BY SENATOR UMBERG
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL FUNCTIONAL
AWARENESS DAY GENERAL BERG
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
AND ASKS FOR YOUR RECOGNITION
AND SUPPORT THE C. R. ONE
HUNDRED WHICH MEMORIALIZES
TOMORROW MAY TENTH IS NATIONAL
SENTINEL AWARENESS DAY- IS A-
FORMER DEPUTY DRUG CZAR I'VE
SEEN FIRSTHAND THE SCOURGE THAT
. ILLEGAL DRUGS CAN CAUSE
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS- BUT
FEDERAL IS IN A CLASS BY ITSELF
FENNEL IS MUCH MORE TOXIC THAN
ANYTHING WE REALLY EVER
EXPERIENCE BEFORE FENNEL
OVERDOSES ARE GROWING THREAT TO
OUR COUNTRY. QUICKLY BECOMING
ONE OF OUR TOP. PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISES OVER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
AMERICANS DIED AS A RESULT OF
THIS DRUG IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AS A CONSEQUENCE OF INGESTION
AND THE GREATER AVAILABILITY.
FOR THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL FENNEL IS INVOLVED IN
MORE DEATHS OF AMERICANS UNDER
FIFTY THAN ANY OTHER CAUSE OF
DEATH INCLUDING HEART DISEASE
CANCER AND ALL OTHER ACCIDENTS.
ILLEGALLY MADE FENTANYL IT IN
ITS DANGERS WHILE WELL
DOCUMENTED BY HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE LARGELY UNKNOWN
TO THE GENERAL POPULATION EVEN
MORE SO TO THE VULNERABLE
POPULATION OF YOUNG ADULTS AMONG
TEENAGERS OVERDOSE DEATHS.
LINKED TO SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS LIKE
FENTANYL TRIPLED THE LAST TWO
YEARS. YET 73% OF YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE NEVER HEARD OF FAKE
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS BEING MADE
WITH FENNEL. RESPONSE TO THE
INTRODUCTION OF THIS RESOLUTION
I RECEIVED A NUMBER OF HEART
BREAKING STORIES FROM
CONSTITUENTS AND FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHAT ARE YOU KNOW
YOUR OWN STORIES OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHOSE LIVES HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATED BY FENNEL JOE
FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH SAID I
LOST MY SISTER. TONY TO AN
ACCIDENTAL FENTANYL OVERDOSE ON
OCTOBER FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SHE WAS PRESCRIBED LARGE
AMOUNTS OF OPIATES FOLLOWING
BACK SURGERY BECAME ADDICTED.
SHE WAS POISONED BY FENTANYL AND
SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT SHE WAS
TAKING AS THAT ADDICTION BECAME
WORSE AND SHE DID NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO LEGAL OPIOIDS. SHE WAS
MY BEST FRIEND I MISS HER EVERY
DAY. ROSA FROM LONG BEACH NOTED
UNFORTUNATELY FEDERAL TOOK THE
LIFE OF MY ONLY DAUGHTER MY ONLY
CHILD IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
THE NEW SHOULDN'T DICTION ISSUE
BUT NEVER THOUGHT SHE WOULD DIE
I'M SURE SHE HAD NO CLUE WHAT
PH<c.cyan> NAS. THE TRAGEDY IS</c>
BROKEN OUR FAMILY IN OUR
COMMUNITY OVER THE LOSS OF OUR
PRECIOUS MAYA I'M GLAD THE WORD
IS. NOW OTHER FOR CAN BE AWARE
AND WATCH THEIR CHILDREN. TAMERA
FROM ARCADIA'S SHARED HER STORY
MY SON DIED FROM A FENTANYL
OVERDOSE OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY HE WAS MY ONLY CHILD HAD
A PROBLEM WITH HEROINES EARLY
TWENTIES. BUT HE BEEN CLEAN FOR
SEVEN YEARS WAS GOING THROUGH
SOME PERSONAL ISSUES AND FELL
OFF THE WAGON. IN UNABLE TO
LOCATE HER ONE- TOOK SENTINEL.
BY MISTAKE HE DIED FROM THE
TOXIC OVERLOAD. MY LIFE IS
FOREVER CHANGED THESE ARE JUST A
FEW OF THE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF STORIES. THAT EXIST
HERE IN CALIFORNIA S. C. R. ONE
HUNDRED PROCLAIMS MAY TEN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. NATIONAL FENNEL OR
WHERE IN THE STATE TO SUPPORT
INCREASING INDIVIDUAL AND PUBLIC
AWARENESS. OF THE IMPACT OF FAKE
OR COUNTERFEIT FENTANYL DRUGS ON
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES.
ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
IS GOING TO SEND ALL SENATORS
INFORMATION TO PROMULGATE ABOUT
THE DANGERS OF FENTANYL. IT IS
AMAZING THAT SO LITTLE AWARENESS
OF THIS DANGEROUS DRUG. EXISTS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND IN
CLOSING IN MEMORY OF MY IN
SUPPORT OF THE GRIEVING FENNEL
RELATED DEATHS LIKE JOE ROSEN.
TAMERA I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU READY FOR
THE DESCRIPTION OF THE VAN ON
THE SIDE OF CENTER DOORS SO.
THANK YOU THE MORNING AND I- I
GOOD AFTERNOON I I'VE READ RISE
IN SUPPORT OF A C. R. ONE
HUNDRED. ALSO YOU KNOW HAVING
WORKED ON A ON A BILL THAT OPENS
REDUCE CANNABIS TO HELP PEOPLE
THAT ARE. ARE ON THEIR LAST DAYS
ARE SUFFERING FROM CANCER- AS AS
A BETTER OPTION TO FACTIONAL ON
HAVING MET WITH FAMILIES WHO
HAVE. LOST LOVED ONES TO CANCER
WHO. BASICALLY WERE UNDER-
FENTON ALL CARE. AND SEEING HOW
THAT AFFECTED THEIR BEHAVIOR AND
THAT AFFECTED THEIR LIVES. BUT
YOU KNOW I KNOW IN SAN DIEGO
IT'S A BIG PROBLEM ILLEGAL
FENTANYL IS A BIG PROBLEM SAN
DIEGO AND IT'S CLAIMING LIVES
IT'S DESTROYING LIVES. AND IT'S
HURTING FAMILIES IN A BIG WAY
AND I KNOW THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY TO TRY
TO FIND A WAY TO RESPOND TO THIS
INCREASE OF THE LEGAL FENTANYL.
BUT ALSO DESERVES TO BE SAID.
THAT THAT I STILL FIND IT
INCREDIBLE THAT THAT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL CANNABIS IS STILL
CONSIDERED A CLASS FIVE. DRUG
WHILE FENTON ALSO CLASS TO. AND
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
BECAUSE HAD THAT NOT BEEN SO
FENTON ALL WOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN
INVENTED. AND THE EFFECTS IT'S
HAVING ON PEOPLE'S LIVES IS JUST
COMPLETELY DESTRUCTIVE. SO I YOU
KNOW WE IT HAS I HOPE THAT WE
INCLUDE IN THIS EFFORT JUSTIN
AWARENESS O WASHINGTON. THAT
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
GIVE UP PEOPLE THAT ARE
SUFFERING FROM A DEBILITATING
PAIN- AND CANNABIS IS AN OPTION
I I'M NOT THE BIGGEST PROMOTER
OF CANNABIS OR NOT EVEN A
PROMOTER OF CANNABIS BUT I HAVE
LEARNED. THAT IS A GREAT OPTION
FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT IN PAIN
AND INSTEAD AND IT HAS NO- SIDE
EFFECTS THAT ARE ANYWHERE CLOSE
TO THAT OF FENTON ALL AND IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE DESTRUCTIVE
PROPERTIES AS FEDERAL SO- I HOPE
THAT- THIS CAL CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO LEAD IN THE AREA OF
RAISING AWARENESS BUT ALSO
PUSHING WASHINGTON TO DO BUT THE
RIGHT THING BY- PROPERLY
CLASSIFIED DRUGS THAT HAVE JUST
SUCH A HORRIFIC EFFECTS. ON
PEOPLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON. THIS PRESENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE SENATE
. IT ECONOMIC SPHERES OF THE
REVOKE HERBAL RULE OF SUPPLY.
AND DEMAND. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS IT'S DRIVING IN THIS
OUTRAGEOUS INFILTRATION. IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN AMERICA. IS
INSIDIOUS INDIVIDUALS. FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES. HAVE FOUND OUR
OPEN BORDERS A WONDERFUL COMBO
CON DO IT. FOR SUCH DANGEROUS
SHARKS IT IS NO WONDER THAT
THOSE BORDER STATES ARE OF THE
MOST AFFECTED. IN THE WORLD. AND
INDEED CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN SO
AFFECTED. FILLERS WE ADDRESS THE
CRISIS IN THE DISASTER. IN THE
HEART WRENCHING STORAGE. LET'S
KEEP IN MIND THE SUPPLY. CAN I
ASK WASHINGTON DC TO DO ITS PART
. TO CURTAIL THIS FREE FLOW. A
FENTANYL INTO OUR COUNTRY. I
CERTAINLY AN ENTHUSIASTICALLY
YOUR GINGIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
VOTE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT OF
LIKE TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM ORANGE COUNTY
OFFERING THIS FORWARD RECENTLY I
SANTEE ON OUR MASS MAILING TO MY
DISTRICT REGARDING THE DANGERS
OF FAT NOW AND IT REALLY MADE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT THE
DIFFERENCE WE RECEIVED MANY MANY
OUR RESPONSES THANKING US FOR
THAT AND THAT CERTAINLY IS
AVAILABLE ON FOR ANY OF YOU THAT
WOULD LIKE TO USE IT BECAUSE IT
MADE A DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF.
THEM UNDERSTANDING THAT FAN MAIL
AND LEISTEN TO OPIATES AND SOME
OF THE MEDICINES THEY MAY BE
TAKING IS EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
TWO MINUTES AND YOU ARE ALL
GONE- SO THANK YOU AGAIN AND I
RISING VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF THE GREAT
EARNING CHAIN NINE SENATOR AMBER
WE TALKED CLOSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES- THANK YOU
FOR THOSE COMMENTS- SADLY THE
SUPPLIERS OF FENNEL COME IN ALL
SHAPES SIZES. COLORS AND
RELIGIONS AS DO THOSE WHO-
UNFORTUNATELY EITHER KNOWINGLY
OR UNKNOWINGLY- TAKE FENNEL. THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAY THAT WE HEAR
CAN. ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
FENTANYL ABUSE FENNEL DESKS IS
BY COMMUNICATING AND PERHAPS THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO
COMMUNICATE A KITCHEN TABLE AS
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF KNOWING.
WHAT ONE IS INGESTING AND
KNOWING THE DANGERS OF FOR
EXAMPLE OPIATE OPIATE
DERIVATIVES AND OPIOD SYNTHETICS
AND I WOULD URGE ALL OF US TO
PROMULGATE THAT INFORMATION AS
WIDELY AS BROADLY AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN I URGE I HAVE VOTE. THANK
YOU MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN. HERE IN C.
NINE OZ THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY NINE SENATOR
ARCHULETA. HE'S PREPARED
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE OF TWO
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL MILITARY APPRECIATION
MONTH CENTER ARTILLERY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRED. MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT S. C. R.
ONE OH TWO DECLARING MAY AS
NATIONAL MILITARY APPRECIATION
MONTH AS WE COME TOGETHER IN
AMERICA TO HONOR OUR MEN AND
WOMEN WHO ARE SERVING IN THE
ARMY NAVY AIR FORCE MARINE CORPS
COAST GUARD. IN OF COURSE THE
SPECIAL OR THE SPACE FORCE IN
THE MONTH OF MAY AMERICA GATHERS
AROUND ITS MILITARY FAMILIES TO
HONOR REMEMBER RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE THOSE WHO SERVE AND
HAVE SERVED. AND REFLECT IN OUR
SHARED HISTORY OF SERVICE AND
DUTY TO COUNTRY. NATIONAL
MILITARY APPRECIATION MONTH
INCLUDES. LOYALTY DAY VICTORY IN
EUROPE DAY MILITARY SPOUSE
APPRECIATION DAY ARMED FORCES
DAY AND OF COURSE MEMORIAL DAY.
THESE ARE MORE THAN THIRTY MAJOR
DEFENSE. CALIFORNIA HAS MORE
THAN THIRTY- DEFENSE
INSTALLATIONS INCORPORATING ALL
MILITARY SERVICES MORE THAN ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE UNION. EACH
OF THESE BASES HAS A UNIQUE
IMPORTANT MILITARY VALUE AND
EACH IS MAKING CRITICAL
CONTRIBUTION TO NATIONAL
SECURITY TODAY AND IN THE FUTURE
ACCOUNTING FOR OVER
1-008-400-0500 AND FIFTY ACTIVE
DUTY NATIONAL GUARD AND RESERVE
PERSONNEL STATIONED HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MONTH HONORS REMEMBERS
RECOGNIZES AND APPRECIATES ALL
MILITARY PERSONNEL WHO HAVE
SERVED THOSE WHO ARE SERVING.
AND OUR HISTORY OF SERVICE ALL
THOSE WHO ARE SERVING NOW IN
UNIFORM ESPECIALLY WE PRAY THAT
THEY ARE SAFE AND OF COURSE
THEIR FAMILIES AS WELL AS THOSE
AMERICANS WHO HAVE GIVEN THEIR
LIVES IN DEFENSE OF OUR FREEDOM
IN OUR COUNTRY TODAY. FOR THESE
REASONS I ASKED TO HAVE YOU ALL
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
MAY AS A NATIONAL MILITARY
APPRECIATION DAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF IT
ON THE SIDE OF. ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OR THE RATE ON THE
SIDE OF THREE NINE MEMBERS JUST
TO IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE. YOUR NEED
SOONER HOURS THIRTY THREE KNOWS
IS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR
SENATOR NEWMAN. SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE OF SIX BY SENATOR
NEWMAN RELATIVE TO COSTS
APPRECIATION DAY SOONER NEWMAN-
MISTER PRESIDENT SANDERS I AM
VERY PLEASED TO PRESENT AS HERE
ONE OH SIX COMMEMORATING MAY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS
COSTA APPRECIATION DAY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATES FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS CASA VOLUNTEERS PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN ADVOCATING FOR
THE BEST INTEREST YOUR CHILDREN
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM ACROSS
OUR GREAT STATE THERE ARE
CURRENTLY MORE THAN SIXTY
THOUSAND YOUTH IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AS A RESULT OF ABUSE
NEGLECT OR ABANDONMENT IN MANY
CASES THESE CHILDREN ARE ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE. TO FALLING THROUGH
THE CRACKS OF A CHRONICALLY
OVERBURDENED CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THAT CANNOT ALWAYS
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT ATTENTION TO
EACH CHILD WHOSE LIFE AND WELL
BEING HAVE BEEN ENTRUSTED TO IT
IN TWENTY TWENTY EVEN IN THE
MIDST OF THE PANDEMIC ALMOST
NINE THOUSAND CASA VOLUNTEERS
WERE STILL ABLETO SUPPORT. MORE
THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND FOSTER
CHILDREN ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE
HIGHLY COMMITTED WELL TRAINED
COMMUNITY VOLUNTEERS GET A
UNIQUE UNDERSTANDING AND
PERSPECTIVE OF THEIR CHILD'S
NEEDS AND EXPERIENCE IN THE
FOSTER SYSTEM UPON COMPLETION OF
SPECIALIZED TRAINING THEY
RECEIVE A COURT APPOINTMENT TO
SERVICE OUR FOSTER USED ADVOCATE
AND VOICE IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH ALLOWS THEM
TO REPRESENT THE CHILD'S BEST
INTEREST BEFORE JUDGES. AND
OTHER KEY PLAYERS IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM MY WIFE DARCY AND
I HAVE BOTH HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING AS CASAS THROUGH THAT
SERVICE I GAINED A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF JUST HOW
COMPLEX. NOW WELL FIRST HOW
WELDING IT CAN BE FOR THE CHILD
WHO MAY NOT HAVE HAD AND
INVESTED COMMITTED ADULTS TO
HELP THEM ALONG THE WAY THROUGH
THEIR JOURNEY AS A RESULT. IN
ROLE BECAUSE OF. WHAT THE END OF
ALL TO A SAFE AND LOVING
ENVIRONMENT AS PART OF AN
OVERALL FOSTER SYSTEM THAT
RESPECTS AND SERVES BOTH THEIR
NEEDS AND THEIR RIGHTS I ASK
THAT YOU JIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
CONTRIBUTIONS OF COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATES BY DESIGNATING
MAY SECOND TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AS COSTA APPRECIATION DAY
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON AS C. R. ONE OH SIX.
SHE NOT. ELIGIBLE FOR YOU NOT
ROLL CALL AS YOU'RE IN OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL FOR
S. C. R. ONE SIX. HEARING CHAIN
NINE OZ THIRTY THREE KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FARMS SYNERGY FOR BOTH.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE OH
EIGHT BY SENATOR OCHO OF BOTH
RELATIVE TO MOTHER'S DAY SOONER
CHAU VOTE. MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
AWAIT RECOGNIZES MAY NINE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS MOTHER'S DAY.
MOTHER'S PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN EDUCATING CARING FOR AND
RAISING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
ARTISTS SCIENTISTS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS. ARE MOTHERS ARE DEEP
COLORS AND SOUL OF OUR SOCIETY.
CALIFORNIA MOTHERS ARE TEACHERS
LEGISLATORS CARETAKERS ENGINEERS
ENTREPRENEURS ATHLETES AND HAVE
MANY DIFFERENCES PROFESSIONS
THEY SIT ON OUR BOARDS AND
VOLUNTEER IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
MOTHER SET AN EXAMPLE FOR
CHILDREN AND HOW TO BE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZERS HELPFUL NEIGHBOURS
AND FEARLESS LEADERS. EACH DAY
MOTHERS PROVIDE COUNSEL AND
SERVE AS AN EXAMPLE TO THEIR
CHILDREN AND PASS ON THE VALUES
THAT IMPACT THEIR LEGACY FOR
GENERATIONS. THIS MOTHER'S DAY
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHOWCASE A DIVERSE ARRAY OF
MOTHERS ACROSS THE STATE WELL
SPENDING EXTRA TIME HONORING THE
MOTHER FIGURES IN OUR LIVES.
EACH DAY MOTHERS AND RICHER
LIVES BY PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES
TO GROW PHYSICALLY EMOTIONALLY
INTELLECTUALLY AND SPIRITUALLY.
WE RECOGNIZE THE MANY WOMEN WHO
ARE WORKINGMOTHERS AND SINGLE
MOMS IN THE UNITED STATES ALONE
OVER TWENTY THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION WOMEN ARE WORKING
MOTHERS AND ONE IN FOUR MOTHERS
ARE RAISING THEIR CHILDREN
WITHOUT A SPOUSE OR PARTNER.
THESE WOMEN MAKE DAILY
SACRIFICES IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES WHILE RAISING
THEIR CHILDREN. WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE BIRTH MOTHERS WHO
THROUGH THEIR SELFLESS LOVE AND
SELF REFLECTION DECIDED TO GIVE
THE BABY TO OTHER FAMILIES TO
ENJOY THE MIRACLE OF PARENTHOOD
. I REMEMBER THE TIME WHEN I
BECAME AWARE THAT I WAS GOING TO
HAVE A BABY AND IT WAS A MIRACLE
FOR ME BECAUSE I HAD BEEN. TOLD
THAT I WOULD HAVE DIFFICULTIES
CONCEIVING SO FOR ME LEARNING OF
MY PREGNANCY WAS ACTUALLY THE
MOST JURIES ARE MIRACLE EVENT IN
MY LIFE AND I REMEMBER PREPARING
FOR THAT BABY TRYING TO PURCHASE
AS MANY BOOKS AND READ AS MUCH
AS I COULD IN ORDER TO. AND
PROVIDE THE BEST OF ENVIRONMENT
FOR THOSE FOR MY CHILDREN AND TO
THIS DAY I CAN SAY THAT. AARON
TO BEING A MOTHER- IS THE
GREATEST EXPERIENCE I'VE HAD IN
MY LIFE BOTH PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY. AND I JUST I'M
JUST GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE EXPERIENCE A
MOTHER IN IT IS IN MY OPINION-
THE GIFT THAT I LEAVE I ONCE I
AM DONE IN PARTNER- DEPARTED
FROM THIS WORLD AND THE LEGACY
THAT I LEAVE BEHIND. THIS STATE
. GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO UP
LIFT THE MOTHER'S FIGURES IN OUR
LIVES WHO SHAPED US INTO THE
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE TODAY THROUGH
CELEBRATING OUR COMMUNITY'S
MOTHERS WE SHOWCASE THE STRENGTH
AND RESILIENCE OF WOMEN WHILE
ALSO REFLECTING ON HOW TO
FURTHER IMPROVE THE LIVELIHOODS
OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING
SEEN NINE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE.
SIXTEEN NINE OZ THIRTY THREE
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE HAVE THE NEXT FIVE
ITEMS IS FILE ITEM. 383-940-6408
FORTY NINE SO. I'M SORRY DID.
THIRTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY
NINE. WE JUST SET OUT NEXT UP IS
THIRTY SIX. THIRTY SIX THIRTY
EIGHT THIRTY NINE FORTY SIX AND
FORTY EIGHT SO JUST WANT THOSE
MEMBERS TO BE PREPARED SO WE
CAN. SOLDIER ON THROUGH SO NEXT
UP IS SENATOR BACKER HE'S
PREPARED SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
NFL EIGHT NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR BACKER AN ACT RELATING
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES CENTER
BECKER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR UP
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY THREE
FOCUS ON THE SAN MATTEO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT WILL
MAKE ANY COLLEGE MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR STUDENTS MOST IN NEED IN
THAT DISTRICT. IT IS WELL KNOWN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN THIS
CHAMBER THE COST OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IS A SUBSTANTIAL
HURDLE FOR MANY STUDENTS THE
FINANCIAL BARRIERS COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE CAN AMOUNT
TO OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE FULL COST OF ATTENDANCE
INCLUDING ROMAN FEES BOOKS
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING. FOOD AND
OTHER EXPENSES. DO YOU BELIEVE
IT IS BURDEN SB EIGHT NINE THREE
EIGHT WILL HELP THE DISTRICT
BETTER USUAL UTILIZE. EXISTING
LOCAL REVENUE TO ELIMINATE
FINANCIAL HURDLES AND SUPPORT
STUDENTS. WILL EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AN ESTIMATED
FOUR THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS. ON TOP OF THE TWO
THOUSAND RT SERVED IN THE
CURRENT PROMISE SCHOLAR PROGRAM
WITHOUT ANY ADDED COST TO THE
STATE. THANK YOU AND I START TO
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX. INSANE
THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON S. B. EIGHT NINE
THREE. HERE IN CHINA. ALL EYES
THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NONMEMBERS ARE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT
SENATOR CORTESE. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR BY SENATOR CORTEZ
SEE AN ACT RELATING TO SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES SKINNER CORTEZ THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- SENATORS I
RISE TO PRESENT SB EIGHT SEVENTY
FOUR BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES OF MERIT K.
TWELVE IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS. THE SAME
CLARITY THAT IS PROVIDED A
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES IN NON
MERIT DISTRICTS REGARDING THEIR
RIGHT TO RETURN TO THEIR PER
CLASSIFICATION IF THEY'RE
PROMOTED THE FILTER COMPLETE
PROBATION FOR THE NEW POSITION
THE ABSENCE OF PROMOTIONAL
PROBATION PROCEDURES IN THE
EDUCATION CODE ALLOWS FOR THE
POTENTIAL TERMINATION OF
PERMANENT EMPLOYEES AMERISPEC
MERIT DISTRICTS WITHOUT CAUSE.
SB SEVENTY FOUR WILL REMEDY THIS
BY CLARIFYING THAT PROMOTIONAL
PROBATIONARY PERIOD FOR
EMPLOYEES AMERICA DISTRICTS WILL
NOT COST THEM THEIR LIVELIHOODS
THUS ENCOURAGING THEM TO SEEK
PROMOTION THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION IN THE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. ON FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT. HEARING CA NINE MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING NOW THIS ROLL CALL ON
S. B. EIGHT SEVEN FOUR. KERN
SCENE NINE HOURS THIRTY THREE.
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR CAFIERO. HE IS PREPARED
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. CABALLERO
AND RELATIVE TO SOCIAL SECURITY
DISABILITY INSURANCE. CENTER
COPIER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT IS
J. R. EIGHT WHICH CALLS ON
CONGRESS TO EXPAND THE SOCIAL
SECURITY DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAM TO ALLOW CHILDHOOD
DISABILITY RECIPIENTS THE RIGHT
TO MARRY WHOMEVER THEY CHOOSE
WITHOUT THE THREAT OF
TERMINATION TO THE BENEFITS.
SOCIAL SECURITY IS THE MOST
EXPENSIVE SAFE SAFETY NET
PROGRAM IN THE UNITED STATES
WERE HEALTH INSURANCE CAN BE
UNAFFORDABLE FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS DISABILITY HEALTH
BENEFITS OFFER COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORT FOR SEVERE CHRONIC
ILLNESSES AND DISABILITIES AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO EXPENSIVE
COMMERCIAL COVERAGE. AROUND
SIXTY FIVE MILLION ELIGIBLE
WORKING AMERICANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES DEPEND ON THE SOCIAL
SECURITY DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAM FOR MONTHLY LIFESAVING
BENEFITS THIS PROGRAM IS A
LIFELINE. SOME OF DRAW SOCIAL
SECURITY AS THE AGE WHILE OTHERS
HAVE RELIED ON LIFESAVING
SUPPORT SINCE BIRTH YOU FOR
DISABLED BEFORE THE AGE OF
TWENTY TWO MAY QUALIFY FOR
BENEFITS THROUGH THEIR PARENTS
EARNINGS AND ARE KNOWN AS
CHILDHOOD DISABILITYRECIPIENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY INEQUITIES WITHIN
THE PROGRAM PENALIZE CHILDHOOD
DISABILITY RECIPIENTS WHO PURSUE
A LEGAL MARRIAGE WITH THE NON
DISABLED PARTNER CHILDHOOD
DISABILITY RECIPIENTS FATE FACED
THE THREAT OF TERMINATION IF IT
REDUCTION TO THE- A PERSON WHO
IS NOT THE SAME. THOSE WHO RELY
ON BENEFITS FOR INCOME SUPPORT
OR HEALTH COVERAGE MUST DECIDE
BETWEEN CONTINUING THE
LIFESAVING ASSISTANCE OR
MARRYING THEIR SIGNIFICANT
OTHER. EVERY CITIZEN IS
GUARANTEED THE OPTION TO ENTER
INTO A LEGAL WILLING MARRIAGE
HOWEVER MARRIAGE PRESENTS A
FINANCIAL BARRIER TO STEEP FOR
DISABLED AMERICANS WHO ARE
CHILDHOOD DISABILITY DISABILITY
RECIPIENTS CONGRESS MUST AMEND
THE CURRENT DISCRIMINATORY
DISCRIMINATORY STRUCTURE OF THIS
. DISABILITY INSURER BROWN TO
GUARANTEE CHILDHOOD DISABILITY
RECIPIENTS THE RIGHT TO MARRY.
WHOMEVER THEY CHOOSE AND RETAIN
BENEFITS THEY HAVE HAD
THROUGHOUT THEIR ENTIRE LIFE
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING
SEEN NONE THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A YOU KNOW
ASK UNANIMOUS OLL CALL ON S. G.
R. EIGHT. TWO NINE HIGHS THIRTY
THREE. NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NO MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
SENATOR NEWMAN. HE IS PREPARED
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINE FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
NEWMAN AND AFTER RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE SOONER
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT SB NINE FORTY
TWO WHICH WILL AUTHORIZE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO UTILIZE FUNDS UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S LOW CARBON TRANSIT
OPERATIONS PROGRAM OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS L. C. TOP. TO
SUPPORT FREE OR REDUCED FARE
TRANSIT PROGRAMS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS OVER THE PAST DECADE
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
TRANSIT YOU SEE SPROUT
CALIFORNIA HAS TRIED TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT FREE AND REDUCE
TRANSIT FARE PROGRAMS.
UNFORTUNATELY A LACK OF
AVAILABLE FUNDING TO MAINTAIN
PROGRAMS ON A LONG TERM BASIS
HAS STYMIED THOSE EFFORTS THIS
BILL WOULD REDUCE ADMINISTRATORS
WHILE ALLOWING FOR LONGER
PERIODS OF APPROVAL THEREBY
EXPANDING THE BENEFITS OF THE
PROGRAM USING LC TOP FUNDS IN
THIS MANNER WILL PROVIDE FOR THE
LONG. TERM SUSTAINABLE. THE FREE
AND REDUCED. PROGRAMS THAT X.
ACCESS TO PUBLIC TRANSIT AND
CREATE LIFELONG TRANSIT RIDERS
WHILE REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SB NINE FORTY TWO WILL
PROVIDE MULTIPLE SIMULTANEOUS
BENEFITS. THE HOUSE GASES
EXPANDING MASS TRANSIT
UTILIZATION REDUCING CONGESTION
ON OUR STREETS IN OFFERING AN
AVENUE FOR ECONOMIC IMPROVEMENT
TO FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. NEW FOR THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE RATE. I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FOLLOWING FORTY SIX. WITH
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS. EIGHT
FIVE BAKER I PORCHES FIVE
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO HI FOR
TESTING I DALY. DODD. FIVE ZERO
SEVEN FIVE EGGMAN AYE GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
I REQUEST SO I FURTADO I JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA I
LIMON HI MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN.
I CONTROL OF BOTH AYE PAN
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH RUBIO HI
SKINNER I STERN I'M BURKE AYE
AYE CASKEY AYE WIENER. I WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN ATKINS DALLY GROVE JONES.
PAN RALPH STERN WELL. HIGHS
THIRTY ONE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NO MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT
SENATOR HUESO HE IS PREPARED
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WEST SO AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
SOONER HUESO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT OF MEMBERS SOME PRIDE
PRESENT S. B. NINE EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT NINE EIGHT EIGHT.
WHICH IS A SIMPLE CLEANUP BILL
FOR LAST YEAR'S THREE ELEVEN THE
COMPASSIONATE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS ACT OR RYAN'S LAW LAST
YEAR'S BILL MADE REFERENCE TO A
SECTION SIXTEEN FORTY NINE POINT
THREE THAT MADE SOME. HEALTH
FACILITIES AND PHARMACIES
NERVOUS THAT THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO PERFORM CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THAT SECTION
LAST YEAR WE PROMISE BRING THE
BILL BACK. CATION IN THE NOT SO
WE ARE SIMPLY LOOKING FOR IN
THIS BILL. MAN IN THAT LANGUAGE
THAT WAS ADDED LATER IN THE C.
IN THIS SESSION. THAT OF THE
BILL- IS ONLY INTENDED TO
REQUIRE HEALTH FACILITIES TO
ENSURE PROPER STORAGE AND
TRACKING OF THE MEDICATION AND
TO ALLOW CDPH TO MONITOR. THIS
STORAGE AND TRACKING. MAN SO
THIS BILL SIMPLY AIMS TO CODIFY
THAT INTENT. AND WE ARE ACTIVELY
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH C. DPH AND
POSSIBLE REPLACEMENT LANGUAGE-
THAT PROVIDES THE OVERSIGHT THEY
NEED. WHILE REMOVING ANY
AMBIGUITY AND CONFUSION FOR
HEALTH FACILITIES SO THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
SIDE ON. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE SILO HERE
NINETEEN NINE MEMBERS THIS TOO
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL THE
FOLLOWING FORTY EIGHT. HEARING
SEEN. HIS THIRTY THREE NOES ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FORTY NINE. BY SENATOR NEWMAN
HE'S PREPARED RENDON SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE SENATE BILL NINE
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR NEWMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS
SENATOR NEWMAN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
RESENT SB NINE NINETY ONE SB
NINE NINETY ONE WILL ALLOW LOCAL
WATER AGENCIES TO CONTRACT WITH
ENTITIES. THAT USE THE
PROGRESSIVE TO DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACTING MODEL IN THE
EXECUTION OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS A CONTRACTING
MODEL IN WHICH A SINGLE ENTITY
IS HARD TO DO BOTH THE DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION WORK AT THE
EARLY STAGE. CHECK IN RECENT IS
THE PROGRESS IT IS BILL MODEL
HAS INCREASED IN POPULARITY
BECAUSE IT OFFERS AN AGENCY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT DURING A
DESIGN BUILDER ON OF THE PROJECT
CAME IN AN EARLY POINT IN THE
DESIGN PHASE THIS COLLABORATION
CAN. BOB RISK COPS AND JUDGES IN
DATA AND FORECASTS SHOW THE
CALIFORNIA NEED NEED TO DEVELOP
SIXTY ADDITIONAL CAPACITY TO
WATER FORTUNATELY TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENTS OF OPEN THE DOOR TO
NEW OPPORTUNITIES TO CONVERT
WASTEWATER INTO DRINKING WATER
TO DO SO AT SCALE THOUGH
CALIFORNIA PROGENY SIX HUNDRED
LOCAL WATER AGENCIES WILL NEED
TO STE ACTUALLY VAST. IN NEW
STRUCTURE THAN IT BREAKS
INNOVATIVE TREE. BUT AUTHORIZED
BANDIT POSITION PROGRESSIVE BILL
AS I NINETY ONE WILL ALLOW LOCAL
WATER AGENCIES MAKE NECESSARY
COST EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS IN
NEW POP SPROUT. TO MEET THE
STATE. MEANT NEEDS I RISK. ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THIS AFTER.
THANK YOU FURTHER DISCUSSION
RATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING CHAIN
NINE MEMBERS THIS IS AUSABLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USE NEW UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON S. THREE NINE NINE
ONE. NINETY NINE OZ THIRTY
THREE. NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PROCESS. NOW MEMBERS REMOVING ON
THE FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE SENATOR
HUESO HE IS PREPARED SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY BY SENATOR WEST SO AN ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE
AT SIX FIFTY MEDIALLY SOONER
HUESO THANK YOU AGAIN ONCE AGAIN
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF PERCENT
AND SENATE BILL TWELVE EIGHTY.
WHICH WOULD CREATE AN EXEMPTION
TO TIED HOUSE LAWS ALONE SENATOR
STATE UNIVERSITY. TO ENTER INTO
SPONSORSHIP AGREEMENTS WITH
ALCOHOL BURKE BEVERAGE SUPPLIERS
THAT IT'S NEW SNAPDRAGON STADIUM
AND OTHER VENUES ACROSS CAMPUS.
ABOUT THESE THIS LAW WOULD ALLOW
SAN DIEGO STATE TO RAISE THE
CAPITAL NECESSARY TO- IMPROVE
THEIR FACILITIES ONE BEING THE
STADIUM. AND OTHERS BEING THERE
ARENA- IR
THE CALCULUS OPEN AIR THEATRE-
SAID THIS SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE DONE FOR OTHER
UNIVERSITIES SO IT'S NOT. A NEW
ACTION THE SETS PRECEDENT BUT
RATHER- GIVES SAN DIEGO STATE
THE SAME BENEFITS THAT WE HAVE
FOR. OTHER CATS YEAH
UNIVERSITIES SO AGAIN THERE IS
NO UP. HIGHER YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR DISCUSS
OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION INTO A HERE
IN SEEN ON THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A YOU KNOW
THROW CALL. ON FILE ITEM S. B.
TWELVE EIGHTY. HEARING TEN NINE
OZ THIRTY THREE. KNOWS IT ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. ON THE
URGENCY HIS THIRTY THREE NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE. NOW MEMBERS
REMOVING ON THE FILE ITEM FIFTY
TWO BY SENATOR CHOI BOGUE.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN TWELVE BY SENATOR
OCHO A BOAT AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION. SKINNER TOWBOAT IS THE
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN TWELVE SIXTY
HARMONIZED CALIFORNIA'S
MARKETPLACE FACILITATOR LAW WITH
CURRENT PRACTICE BY CLEARLY
IDENTIFYING THE MARKETPLACE
SELLER AS A TAX RESPONSIBLE
PARTY AND CAR RENTAL
TRANSACTIONS FACILITATED BY AN
ONLINE TRAVEL COMPANY MANY
STATES HAVE ADOPTED MARKETPLACE
FACILITATOR LAWS GOVERNING SALES
AND USE TAX REMITTANCE
OBLIGATIONS WHEN BUSINESSES
PARTNER TO SELL GOODS AND OR
SERVICES THROUGH THIRD PARTY
INTERMEDIARIES. CAR RENTAL
CUSTOMERS FREQUENTLY MODIFY
THEIR BOOKINGS AT THE COUNTER
WHICH CAN DRASTICALLY CHANGE THE
TAXES AND OTHER CHARGES THAT
APPLY TO THE RENTAL THIS RESULT
IN THERE BEING MULTIPLE
RETAILERS FOR DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF A SINGLE CAR
RENTAL BOOKING FURTHER
COMPLICATING THE TAX COLLECTION
AND REMITTANCE REQUIREMENTS
UNDER THE NEW MARKETPLACE
FACILITATOR LAW. CAR RENTAL
COMPANIES HAVE DEEP INDUSTRY
KNOWLEDGE COMPLETE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE TRANSACTION AND ARE
UNDERPREPARED TO AUDIT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION SHIFTING THE
TAX RESPONSIBILITY TO PLATFORMS
WORK WHO ARE ILL EQUIPPED TO
NAVIGATE COMPLEXITIES ONLY LEADS
TO CONFUSION FOR THE PLATFORM
RENTAL CAR COMPANIES AND CD TFA
AUDITORS RENTAL CAR COMPANIES
ARE ALREADY REMITTING TAX ON
THESE TRANSACTIONS AND ARE UNDER
CONTINUOUS AUDIT. BY THE STATE.
SB THIRTEEN TWELVE WILL CLEARLY
IDENTIFY THE MARKETPLACE SELLER
AS A TAX RESPONSIBLE PARTY IN
CAR RENTAL TRANSACTIONS WE HAVE
BROUGHT ALL PARTIES TO THE TABLE
INCLUDING THE RENTAL CAR
COMPANIES. THE MARKETPLACE
FACILITATORS AND THE CD TFA IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE
CODIFICATION OF CURRENT CAR
RENTAL TAX REMITTANCE PRACTICES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OF THE RATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN NONE. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON S. B.
THIRTEEN TWELVE. IN NINETEEN
NINE OZ THIRTY THREE KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERSHIP
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE IN FOLLOWING
NEXT ITEMS FOR FIFTY.
576-172-7370 FOUR SO MEMBERS ARE
PREPARED. WE WILL START WITH
FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX. SENATOR
MELENDEZ SHE'S PREPARED
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL EIGHT SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
MELENDEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES CENTER
MELENDEZ. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I'M HONORED TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL EIGHT SIXTY FOUR ASANAS
TYLER'S LINE ON OCTOBER TWENTY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
TYLER SHAMUS DIED IN THE
BATHROOM OF A SOBER LIVING HOME
AFTER HAVING INGESTED FENTANYL.
AT THE EMERGENCY ROOM TYLER WAS
ADMINISTERED TEST FOR OPIOIDS
WHICH AT THE TIME WERE THOUGHT
TO PICK UP TRACES OF FENTANYL
UNFORTUNATELY THAT WAS NOT THE
CASE IT WASN'T UNTIL AFTER TYLER
PASSED AWAY AT THE DOCTRINE
TYLER'S FAMILY WERE INFORMED
THAT THE STANDARD TOXICOLOGY
SCREEN DOES NOT IDENTIFY
SYNTHETIC FORMS OF FENTANYL. SB
EIGHT SIXTY FOUR IS ABOUT MAKING
SURE EMERGENCY ROOM DOCTORS CAN
PLAY A KEY ROLE IN IDENTIFYING
OVERDOSES PRE SCREENING FOR FAN
ON HOSPITAL WHENEVER YOU'RE IN
DRUG SCREENING IS ORDERED TO
THEY- CAN ASSIST IN DIAGNOSING A
PATIENT'S CONDITION. THIS FORMER
RAPID TESTING FOR SYNTHETIC FAT
NO HAS BECOME SO SUCCESSFUL THAT
THE MAJORITY OF HOSPITALS IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY INCLUDE FEDERAL
TESTING ANYTIME. A URINE DRUG
SCREEN IS ORDERED THIS MEASURE
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND
WIPE WIDE. BY SUPPORT. AND I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING SEE NAINA
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ON
S. B. H. SIX FOUR. JEAN NINE
HIGHS THIRTY THREE. NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW ON TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN SENATOR LAWYER.
IS REPAIRED SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN OH
FIVE BY SENATOR LAYERED AN ACT
RELATING TO THE STATE VEHICLE
FLEET CENTER LURK THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT OF THE STATE'S CURRENT
VALUATION METHODOLOGY FOR LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLE ACQUISITION
CONTRACTS WAS LAST UPDATED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WHEN THE
STATE WAS PURCHASING A LOT OF
FLEX FUEL VEHICLES. NOW IF YOU
WANTED TO DO A STATE CONTRACT
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE A PLUG
IN HYBRID A HYBRID ELECTRIC
VEHICLE YOU HAVE TO DO AN
ELABORATE METHODOLOGY DESIGNED
TO WEIGH THE MERITS OF
ALTERNATIVE FUELS WHICH IS JUST
COMPLETELY OUTDATED THIS BILL
WOULD UPDATE THAT STILL REQUIRE
THE EXISTING METHODOLOGY FOR.
VEHICLES POWERED SOLELY BY
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINES THIS
BILLS RECEIVE NO NO VOTES AS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I ASKED
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR THE VERY.
HEARING CHAIN NINE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN. ALLEN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. EIGHT BACKER
I PORCHES. BRADFORD. HI
CABALLERO HYPERTENSIVE AYE DALY
DODD FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL AYE FURTADO
AYE JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED
AYE LEYVA. I LIMON I MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ. MANY AYE NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A CHOI BOGUE I PAN.
PORTANTINO I ROTH RUBIO AYE
SKINNER I STERN. I'M BURKE HI MY
CASTING AYE WIENER AYE WILK. DR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN ATKINS BATES I. FOR JUST.
DALLY GROVE MELENDEZ NIELSEN PAN
ROTH STERN WILK. TWENTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM SIXTY ONE SENATOR GLAZERS
HE'S PREPARED SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY
SIX BY SENATOR GLAZER AND AFTER
LEADING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
GLAZER FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB TWELVE
THIRTY SIX FOOT WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS THE OPTION
THE OPTION TO GRANT THE STUDENT
MEMBER OF THEIR BOARD FULL
VOTING RIGHTS. CURRENTLY STUDENT
MEMBERS- CAN EXPRESS THEIR
OPINION BUT THERE VOTE DOES NOT
COUNT GIVING LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
THIS OPTION IT CAN FURTHER
EMPOWER STUDENTS WHILE RETAINING
THE ABILITY OF THE SCHOOL BOARDS
TO TAKE THEIR STUDENT MEMBERS
VOTING RIGHTS TO MEET THE
DESIRES OF THAT COMMUNITY.
SEVERAL STATE EDUCATION BOARDS
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA ALREADY
GRANT FULL VOTING RIGHTS TO
STUDENTS. THIS BILL DOES THREE
THINGS. INCREASES TO
REPRESENTATION BY PERMITTING
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS TO GRANT
FULL VOTING RIGHTS TO THEIR
STUDENT MEMBERS. NUMBER TO
MAINTAIN LOCAL CONTROL BY GIVING
SCHOOL BOARDS THE FLEXIBILITY TO
VOTE. ON GRANTING FOR VOTING
RIGHTS TO THEIR MEMBERS. AND
NUMBER THREE ALLOWS THE SCHOOL
BOARDS TO RESTRICT THE STUDENT
NUMBER FROM VOTING ON CERTAIN
TOPICS WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I HAVE A- ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE. IN NINETEEN
NINE LOS SOONER JONES. A-QUESTION FOR THE AUTHORED BY MY
MISTER SENATORS REJECT QUESTION
. AT THANK YOU CENTER I WAS JUST
WONDERING- IF THE NOW THIS IS A
THAT I'M READING IS ACTOR NOT
DOES THE STUDENT MEMBERS VOTE
HAVE A LEGAL AUTHORITY AND
COUNTS TOWARDS THE ACTION OF THE
COMPLETE BOARD. SENATOR GLAZERS
YES OKAY THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING CHAIN NINE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS BASE.
BAKER HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD AYE
CABRERA AYE FOR TESTING I DALY
DODD HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I REQUEST SO HI
FURTADO I JONES NO KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA AYE LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO MAN AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. NOTRE ARE
BOTH. HI PAM PORTANTINO. I ROTH
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I STERN I'M
BURKE HI MIKE HOW SKI I WIENER.
HI WILK. SIX TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ATKINS.
EIGHT DALLY GROW. PAN RALPH
STERN WILK AYE AYES TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS FOR. I'M SORRY. SENATOR
BATES STATE WROTE. BATES NO. I
JUST TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
TWO SENATOR EGGMAN SHE'S
PREPARED SECRETARY ME READ.
SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN AN ACT RELATING
TO CONSERVATORSHIP SOONER EGGMAN
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AT
TODAY PERCENT SB NINE SIXTY FIVE
WHICH WOULD CREATE A HEARSAY
EXEMPTION IN THE CONSERVATORSHIP
PROCEEDINGS. WHEN A MEDICAL
EXPERT WITNESS TESTIFIED TO THE
MEDICAL HISTORY OF A CONSERVANCY
BASED ON THE MEDICAL RECORDS
LIMITED MEDICAL HISTORY DIRTY
CHILDREN A CONSERVATORSHIP
PROCEEDING LEAVES THE JUDGE
WITHOUT RELEVANT DETAILS OF THE
CONSERVATIVES MENTAL HEALTH AND
DOES NOT PROVIDE A COMPLETE
PICTURE OF WHETHER SOMEONE IS
GRAVELY DISABLED. BECAUSE HE'S
EXPERT WITNESSES ARE NOT TREATED
THE TREATING PHYSICIAN MUCH OF
THE RELEVANT MEDICAL HISTORY
CONTAINED IN THE MEDICAL RECORD
IS INADMISSIBLE RATHER LIMITING
THE RELEVANT INFORMATION
PROVIDED TO JUDGE WE SHOULD BE
ENSURING THAT EACH CONSERVATIVE
RECEIVED A THOROUGH REVIEW. OF
THE RELEVANT FACTS OF THEIR
MENTAL CONDITION TO AVOID
FURTHER CYCLING AND POTENTIAL
DECOMPENSATION I ASK FOR YOUR
ALBUM. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SHE NINE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
AND UNANIMOUS ?L
ITEM SEVENTY TWO. HEARING NINE
ALL EYES THIRTY THREE NOES ZERO
THE MEASURE PROCESS. NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY THREE. MELENDEZ SHE'S
REPAIRED SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TEN BY
SENATOR MELENDEZ AN ACT RELATING
TO TRESPASS CENTER MELINDA'S
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I'M
HONORED TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TEN WHICH EXTENDS THE
TIME A TRESPASS LETTER OF
AUTHORITY ALSO KNOWN AS A SIXTY
TWO LETTER IS VALID FROM TWELVE
MONTHS TO THREE YEARS EXTENDING
THE TIME IS SIXTY TWO LETTERS
VALID ALLEVIATE THE TIME
COMMITMENT BURDEN PLACED ON
LOCAL SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT STAFF
TO PROCESS PAPERWORK. THIS BILL
ALSO SEEKS TO MODERNIZE THE
PROCESS BY ALLOWING NOTARIZED
APPLICATIONS TO BE SUBMITTED
ELECTRONICALLY WITHOUT THE NEED
TO VISIT LOCAL OFFICES DURING
BUSINESS HOURS I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE ELIMINATED
THEIR CONCERNS THE AMENDMENTS
REDUCE THE SIX A TWO LETTER
BALLOT TIME FROM FIVE YEARS DOWN
TO THREE YEARS IN CREATED
NOTIFICATION PROCESS WHERE THE
PURCHASER OF THE PROPERTY WITH A
VALID SIXTY TWO LETTER ON FILE
MUST NOTIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT OF A
CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP FOR THAT
LETTER TO REMAIN IN FOR. WITH
THERE'S A MAP IS BOTH AT THE
PUMP BOTH THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS
IN THE ACLU HAVE REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE
OF ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HEARING SEEING NONE
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USE THE- ALL.
HEARING CHANGE ARE THIRTIETH NO
ZERO THE MEASURE. PROMISES NEXT
UP IS. THIRTY CENTER WINNER USED
. SECTOR ME READ. SENATE BILL
NINE THIRTY SENATOR WIENER AN
ACT RELATING TO HOUSING. CENTER
WINNER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
NINE THIRTY- THIS BILL WILL
EXPAND THE PROTECTIONS IN THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT- THE
PROJECTS ARE. FOR EXTREMELY LOW
IN INCOME INDIVIDUALS ARE YOU
THOSE MAKING UP 230% OF THE AREA
MEDIAN INCOME. THIS INCOME
CATEGORY OF CALIFORNIANS IS IN
DESPERATE NEED OF HOUSING WITH
74% OF THESE HOUSEHOLD SPENDING
MORE THAN HALF OF THEIR INCOME.
ON A HOME EXPERIMENT IT'S A IT'S
A COVER EXTREMELY EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME. HOUSING IS A COMMON
SENSE THAT OVER TO MEASURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR. HEARING SEE
NONE OF MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SENATOR
GLAZERS. THE JOB JACKSON TO THE
- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. FIVE ATKINS BATES.
BAKER I PORCHES. FIVE BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE PROTESTING AYE
DALY. DODD I TORONTO I EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE
HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL AYE FURTADO
AYE JONES I KAMLAGER. LAYERED I
LEYVA HI THE MON HI MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN I GO TO A VOTE I PAN.
PORTANTINO I ROTH RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN- BURKE HI WE
CASTING AYE WIENER AYE WILK.
THIRTY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN ATKINS BATES.
DALLY GLAZER GROVE KAMLAGER I.
PAN ROTH KERN WELL. ALL EYES
THIRTY KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS REMOVED ON
THE FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN
SENATOR JONES SECRETARY MARY
SENATE BILL NINE NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR JONES AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS CENTER JONES THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT NATURAL PATHAK
DOCTORS HAVE SOME LIMITATIONS TO
HOW THEY'RE ABLE TO STAFF THEIR
PRACTICES AND BY EXTENSION HOW
THEY'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE CARE FOR
THEIR PATIENTS SB NINE NINETY
FOUR ADDRESSES THESE LIMITATIONS
BY ALLOWING NATURAL PATHAK
DOCTORS TO HIRE LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSES. BEING ABLE TO
HIRE LPNS WOULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON CARE FOR
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
RELY ON THE INDIES FOR THE
PRIMARY CARE WITHOUT CHANGING
THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE BRANDIES
AND FOR LV ENDS I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
CHAIN NINE MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR YOU KNOW I'M SURE- CALLS OR
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN. YOU SEEN ON
AUGUST THIRTY THREE. NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS RUN OUR
FINAL ITEM FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO.
BY SENATOR CAFIERO SHE IS
PREPARED SECRETARY MEMORY.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
BY SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACT
RELATING TO HEAR SAY SENATOR
CAFIERO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW AND NARAL
HEARSAY EXCEPTION FOR THE
STATEMENT OF A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIM. MADE TO A MEDICAL
PROVIDER FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT TO BE
ADMITTED AT TRIAL. VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE AMONG THE
MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND UNFORTUNATELY
CRIMES COMMITTED AGAINST THEM
ARE THE MOST DIFFICULT TO
PROSECUTE BECAUSE THERE ARE FEW
WITNESSES. AND MOST OF THE ABUSE
OCCURS ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS ENORMOUS PRESSURE
IS PUT ON VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FREQUENTLY FROM TEIR
ABUSERS OR FAMILIES TO DENY THE
ABUSE AT THE INDOOR. IN MANY
INSTANCES A MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
THAT SEES THE VICTIM RIGHT AFTER
THE INJURY OR THE ABUSE IS THE
ONLY PERSON TO WHOM A VICTIM
DISCLOSES THE MANNER AND EXTENT
OF THE ABUSE AND INJURY. OUR
LAWS RIGHT POLICE SHIELD VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WHO REFUSED TO TESTIFY FROM
PENAL CONSEQUENCES THEY CANNOT
BE INCARCERATED FOR REFUSING TO
TESTIFY. REFUSING TO TESTIFY IS
NOT HOWEVER INDICATIVE OF A
DESIRE TO BE LEFT UNPROTECTED
AND SO WE PROSECUTE OFFENDERS
WITHOUT FORCING VICTIMS TO
TESTIFY WHERE THEY MAY PUT
THEMSELVES IN GREATER DANGER FOR
ABUSE OR ISOLATION. IN THESE-INSTANCES WHERE VICTIMS CANNOT
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE WOULD ALLOW VICTIMS
TRUTHS TO BE HEARD. THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A HEARSAY EXCEPTION
FOR STATEMENTS MADE BY A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM TO A
MEDICAL CARE PROVIDER FOR
PURPOSES OF MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT. AND FOR STATEMENT
REASONABLY PERTINENT TO MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS OR TREATMENT- A LOT
THE FEDERAL RULES OF EVIDENCE
PERMITS THE STATEMENTS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS GIVEN
TO A MEDICAL CARE PROVIDER FOR
PURPOSES OF MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS.
OR TREATMENT TO BE ADMISSIBLE AT
TRIAL REGARDLESS OF THE VICTIM'S
AVAILABILITY. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE WOULD CONFORM CALIFORNIA'S
RULES PROTECTING VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TO FEDERAL
LAW. AND EVEN BROADER MEDICAL
HEARSAY EXCEPTION IS ALLOWED IN
ILLINOIS MINNESOTA NORTH
CAROLINA OREGON AND RHODE
ISLAND. CALIFORNIA ALSO ALREADY
OFFERS THIS HEARSAY EXCEPTION
FOR CASES OF CHILD ABUSE UNDER
CALIFORNIA EVIDENCE CODE. WITH
THE ASSISTANCE OF BOTH THE
PUBLIC THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND JUDICIARY COMMITTEES I'VE
ADDED ADDITIONAL SAFEGUARDS. ONE
THE BILL IS LIMITED TO USE IN
CRIMINAL CASES ONLY TO THE
STATEMENTS MADE MAY ONLY BE USED
WITH THE VICTIM'S CONSENT AND
THREE. THE NOTICE MUST BE
PROVIDED TO THE DEFENDANT AND
COUNSEL AT LEAST THIRTY DAYS
BEFORE ITS USE. MEDICAL HERE SAY
IS A CRITICAL AND EFFECTIVE TOOL
TO COUNTERACT AN ABUSER'S
MANIPULATIONS AND THREATS THAT
PERFECT. PREVENT VICTIM
TESTIMONY. CONSISTENT AND
EFFECTIVE PROSECUTION OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE HAS A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD OF DECREASING THE
INCIDENCE OF DOMESTIC DOMESTIC
ABUSE. BUT EFFECTIVE PROSECUTION
REQUIRES COMPELLING EVIDENCE. SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE ALLOWS THE
EFFECTIVE PROSECUTION IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES WHERE
THERE IS COMPELLING EVIDENCE
BECAUSE THE VICTIM HAS SOUGHT
MEDICAL CARE AND TREATMENT FOR
THEIR INJURIES. THIS WILL
PROTECT THE VICTIM FROM FURTHER
BROUGH ABUSE AND HONOR THE
VICTIMS RIGHT NOT TO TESTIFY
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF THE BAIT
ON THE SO I DON'T YOU FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE HEARING
NINE MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING. A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALLON S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE. ERNESTINE ON ICE
THIRTY THREE. KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NO MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO RETURN TO MOTIONS ROAD
RESOLUTIONS NOW IT'S TIME FOR A
JOURNEY MEMORIES. I'M RUSHING TO
THIS WE HAVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- SECTOR PLEASE READ. IS
THERE ANY ITEM THAT A MEMBER
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY. IS THERE
ANY ITEM. HEARING CHAIN NINE.
SECRETARY YOU MAY REACH. SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION FIFTEEN SENATE
BILLS. TWELVE TEN TWELVE SEVENTY
TWO ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY
EIGHT SENATE BILLS. EIGHT THIRTY
FIVE TEN FORTY TEN FIFTY FOUR
TEN SIXTY FOUR TEN SEVENTY ONE
ELEVEN TWENTY ELEVEN FIFTY THREE
ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT ELEVEN NINETY
THREE TWELVE THIRTEEN TWELVE
FIFTY NINE THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN
FOURTEEN OR TO FOURTEEN FORTY
FOURTEEN NINETY SIX AND SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN NINETY EIGHT. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. IN NINETEEN
NINE. OUR EYES THIRTY THREE NO
ZERO FILE ITEM ONE FOUR OZ
THIRTY THREE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. NOW IT'S TIME
FOR MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. OUR
AND THIS WOULD BE THE TIME FOR
GERMANY MEMORIES WE HAVE TO A
GERMAN MEMORIES WE FIRST UP OUT
SENATOR CORTESE IF HE'S PREPARED
. PLEASE MEMBERS GIVE MISS
CENTER TO PROTECT YOUR ATTENTION
DURING THIS TIME. YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT WITH DEEP
SADNESS THAT ARISE IN S. SENATE
TO JOURNEY MEMORY OF NORMAN Y.
MINETA. I WAS HONORED TO CALL
SECRETARY MINETA FRIEND AND
MENTOR- I FIRST MET MR MINETA
WHEN I WAS A TWELVE YEAR OLD BOY
IN THE LATE NINETEEN SIXTIES-
WHEN HE JOINED MY FATHER TO HAND
OUT FREE WHOLE WHEAT PUMPKINS TO
KIDS IN THE SAN JOSE. HE WAS
BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY ONE IN
OUR HOMETOWN OF SAN JOSE. HE WAS
SENT WITH HIS FAMILY TO AN
INTERNMENT CAMP IN NINETEEN
FORTY TWO AT THE AGE OF TEN.
WHILE WEARING HIS BOY SCOUT
UNIFORMS. THE ONLY POSSESSION HE
CARRIED AT THE TIME WAS IS
BASEBALL BAT. HIS LITTLE LEAGUE
BASEBALL BAT. WHICH WAS
CONFISCATED AT HEART MOUNTAIN
FOR FEAR IT WOULD BE USED AS A
WEAPON. THE OFFICE SAID THE MOST
HURTFUL THING THAT HE COULD
NEVER FORGET. WAS BEING REFERRED
TO AS A NON ALIEN. HE TOLD THE
TOLD THE STORY OF ASKING HIS
BROTHER WHAT THAT MEANT. IN Y.
GIVEN HIS NATURAL BIRTHRIGHT HE
WASN'T SIMPLY REFERRED TO AS A
CITIZEN. IT WAS A HEART MOUNTAIN
THAT HE MET ALAN K. SIMPSON. IN
IN THE TWIST OF FATE ELLEN
SIMPSON HIMSELF A BOY SCOUT.
FROM MARK WYOMING WHO HAD BEEN
VISITING HEART MOUNTAIN. BECAME
A UNITED STATES CONGRESSMAN
SERVING SIDE BY SIDE WITH NORM
IN CONGRESS. THOSE TWO BECAME
FRIENDS FOR LIFE IN FACT BEST
FRIENDS. HE WAS A TRAILBLAZING
LEADER THAT BROKE BARRIERS FOR
ASIAN AMERICANS SECRETARY MINETA
WAS THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN
FIRST PERSON OF COLOR TO SERVE
ON THE SAN JOSE CITY COUNCIL.
IT'S WORTH NOTING AND I KNOW
THIS FIRSTHAND. THAT ON THE
TOPIC OF AP I HATE. DURING NORMS
FOR CITY COUNCIL CAMPAIGN HE WAS
ADVISED NOT TO USE HIS PHOTO. IN
ANY OF HIS CAMPAIGN MATERIALS
FOR FEAR THAT HE'D LOSE ANTI
ASIAN VOTES. AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT HE DID. LATER HE WAS
ELECTED THE MAYOR OF SAN JOSE
BECAME THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN
TO LEAD A MAJOR CITY IN THE
UNITED STATES. MINISTERED IN
CONGRESS FOR TWENTY YEARS. WHERE
HE LED THE PASSAGE. WITH THE
HELP OF HIS BOYHOOD FRIEND ALAN
SIMPSON SIMPSON OF THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES ACT OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT A FEDERAL LAW THAT
PROVIDED REPARATIONS AND APOLOGY
TO JAPANESE AMERICANS INTO
INTERNMENT CAMPS DURING WORLD
WAR TWO. IN TWO THOUSAND HE
BECAME THE FIRST. ASIAN AMERICAN
TO SERVE AS US SECRETARY OF
COMMERCE. UNDER PRESIDENT
CLINTON AND THEN WAS APPOINTED
BY PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH AS
U. S. SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION. MOST OF US KNOW
THAT ON SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND ONE. IT WAS SECRETARY
MINETA. WHERE TO TAKE CHARGE OF
ALL FHA ACTIVITIES. GROUNDED ALL
AIRCRAFT. ULTIMATELY CREATED
WHAT WE NOW KNOW AS THE
TRANSPORTATION SECURITY AGENCY
OR TSA AND HOMELAND SECURITY. I
WAS IN THE CELLS THE CITY HALL
BY THAT TIME IN ON THAT MORNING
. IN A REMEMBER THEN MAYOR RON
GONZALEZ WALKING INTO MY OFFICE
. TO COMPARE NOTES. THEN THE
FIRST THING HE SAID WAS I THINK
NORM HAS IT ALL UNDER CONTROL
AND THAT'S HOW WE ALL FELT. IN
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE I'M NOT
SURE HOW OTHER CALIFORNIA'S
FELT. ON THAT MORNING THAT DAY
RELATIVE. TO THE SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION BUT IN SAN JOSE
IT WOULD BE AS GOOD AS HAVING.
YOUR FATHER FIGURE. TAKING
CHARGE OF YOUR OWN SECURITY AND
SAFETY. SECRETARY MINETA EMBODY
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A PUBLIC
SERVANT IT WAS AN INSPIRATION TO
COUNTLESS LEADERS INCLUDING
MYSELF. LATER. AFTER TWO
THOUSAND ONE IN FACT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO- GONZALEZ
APPROACHED ME. IN ASKED ME. TO
HELP WITH THE VOTES ON AN ELEVEN
MEMBER COUNCIL TO RENAME SALES
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. NORMAN Y.
MINETA SAN JOSE INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT. OF COURSE- I AGREED
IMMEDIATELY BUT A SUB SCHOOL WE
GOT A CALL. FROM FORMER
CONGRESSMAN MIKE HONDA THEN
STILL IN CONGRESS. ASKING ME TO
PERSONALLY GIVE NORMA CALL. I
CALLED SECRETARY MINETA. ANY
ASKED ME. TO STOP WITH THE
PROCEEDINGS THAT HE WANTED TO
PULL THE ITEM OFF THE COUNCIL
AGENDA THOSE VIEW- FAMILIAR WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WILL SERVE IN
THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE
BROWN ACT KNOW THAT THERE WAS NO
WAY FOR HIM TO KNOW OR US TO
KNOW PRECISELY WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WOULD BE A MAJORITY VOTE.
AND HE SAID BECAUSE OF THAT. IN
THAT LACK OF CERTAINTY HE DIDN'T
WANT TO RISK EMBARRASSING HIS
FAMILY. HIS TWO SONS GOOD
FRIENDS OF MINE LIVING IN SAN
JOSE AND THEIR FAMILIES SAID IT
WASN'T WORTH IT. IT'S NOT WORTH
IT MY FAMILY COMES FIRST. A
REASSURED HIM. AND TOLD HIM WE
HAVE THE VOTES. THAT WASN'T AN
EASY VOTE THERE WERE PARTISAN
OBJECTIONS THAT STANDS TO REASON
. THE PROJECTIONS ABOUT THE
LENGTH OF THE NAME TOO
CUMBERSOME. BUT THE BIGGEST
OBJECTION. WAS THE FACT THAT HE
WAS STILL ALIVE. IT STRUCK ME AS
I WAS PREPARING THESE NOTES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THE NOBODY
HAS TO WORRY ABOUT ANYMORE. HIS
LEGACY WILL LEAVE A LASTING
IMPRESSION FOR YEARS TO COME.
OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO HIS ENTIRE
FAMILY. NASA THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF THIS
DISTINGUISHED LEADERS CIVIL
RIGHTS CHAMPION IN MENTOR TO SO
MANY THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
COURTESY CENTER WHY COST. I TO
RISE AND- MEMORY OF FIVE NORMAN
Y. MINETA THERE WAS A LIGHTER
SIDE OF TECH- SECRETARY MINETA
AND THEN ALL THE OTHER- OF FACTS
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE
HAS SOME. SHARED I MET HIM FORTY
FIVE YEARS AGO I WAS A YOUNG
STAFFER HE WAS SICK IN HIS
SECOND TERM AS AS A CONGRESSMAN-
AND AT THAT TIME. AM I HAVE ON
MY MOM'S A TWIN MY AUNT SOPHIE'S
IN JERSEY SHE'S THE TWIN AND
THEY USED TO DRESS UP WHEN THEY
WE GET TOGETHER MY MOTHER WOULD
BY IDENTICAL CLOTHES SO THERE
ARE FIFTY SIXTY YEARS OLD OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. AND I WAS
ON THE- AND THE- CONGRESSIONAL
RESTAURANTS AND EATING BEANS
WHATEVER YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO EAT
WHEN YOU'RE THERE AND HE COMES
UP AND INTRODUCES HIMSELF TO MY
MOTHER MY AUNT AND YOU KNOW YOU
SEE TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD KID
THAT'S WE DON'T DO THAT WE DON'T
GO TO THE RESTAURANTS AND SAY
HEY STAFF PERSON FOR ANOTHER
MEMBER HOW YOU DOING WHO ARE
THESE PEOPLE HERE. IN YEARS
LATER SIX SEVEN YEARS LATER HE
WALKS UP TO AT SOME OF IT WHEN
I'M WITH MY MOTHER IN SAYS HELEN
HOW ARE YOU DOING. AND HOW IS
YOUR SISTER SOPHIE. AND THOSE
WERE THINGS THAT NORMAN ADDED
DID ALL THE TIME TO FOLKS- MY BY
STANDARD WORDS- AND PETE STARK
IN NORMAN AT A HAD PLACES ON
THE- CHESAPEAKE BAY SUVI SUSIE
ELVING WHICH WAS. IN A LESS
FRANCIS WAS HIS FIRST CHIEF BUT
SUSIE WAS THE CHIEF FOR A LONG
TIME SHE WAS OUT THERE JIM
COPELAND AND- DEBBIE MCFARLAND
THERE THEY WE HAD THIS LITTLE
GAGGLE OF SAN JOSE HANDS THEIR
WORST BAY AREA PEOPLE THAT HAD.
PLACES THERE IN. WE NEVER GOT
INVITED BECAUSE WE'RE ONLY JUST
STAFF BUT BUT IT WAS IT WAS A
NORMAL LIFE BE. MISSED READ
WORDS AND THAT COPELAND'S WOULD
TELL US ABOUT THE FUND THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE WITH THE KIDS DAVID
AND ALL THE KIDS OUT THERE WHEN
THEY WERE GROWING UP. AND THEY
FORGET YOU FORGET WHEN YOU HEAR
THESE MONUMENTS- THAT PEOPLE
HAVE HE- SAID IT WAS ALWAYS
SURPRISED THAT HIS PARENTS WOULD
NAME HIM AFTER AN AIRPORT. THAT
WAS HIS HIS JOKE YOU KNOW WHEN
PEOPLE SAY HOW DID YOU GET AN
AIRPORT NAMED AFTER HE WOULD
TURN AROUND AND HE WAS SELF
DEPRECATING IN THAT WAY DID YOU
SAY I DON'T KNOW WHY MY PARENTS
NAME. AND AIRPORT AFTER ME- HE-
WAS. AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TENNESSEE SAID IT REALLY HURT
HIM- WHEN HE WAS IDENTIFIED AS
SAID A NINETY MILLION AND NON
CITIZEN AND HE AND IT THAT WAS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HE
CHERISHED IS THAT IS THAT SB
EVEN AS A TEN YEAR OLD I CAN'T
HAVE MY GOVERNMENT NOT RECOGNIZE
ME AS A CITIZEN SO- HERE'S TO
YOU- NORMAN Y. MINETA. AND
ADJOURNMENTS MEMORY. THANK YOU
AND WE STAND THE DEEPEST SENATE.
CONDONE ALL WE HAVE SENATOR DODD
AS WELL ON THIS MATTER. THANK
YOU MEMBERS- I WOULD TO GET TO
GET UP TALK TODAY BUT I DO WANT
TO FIVE WANTED TO POINT OUT
WHICH IS TO A WONDERFUL HUMAN
BEING HE WAS THOSE YOU'LL
REMEMBER THAT WE'RE HERE AT THE
TIME FOR THE WOMAN OF THE YEAR
CELEBRATION I BELIEVE IT WAS.
THREE YEARS AGO- MY WOMAN OF THE
YEAR WAS FROM- OF COURSE NAPA
AND SHE HAD BEEN A STAFFER AND
HER HUSBAND HAVE BEENA STAFFER-
FORGET FOR- THEN CONGRESSMAN
MINETA IN HE FLEW WITH HIS WIFE
FROM COLORADO. TO SACRAMENTO
JUST TO SEE HIS FORMER STAFFER
YET- HER RECOGNITION FOR THE
WOMAN OF THE YEAR AND THAT'S
WHAT KIND OF HUMAN BEING HE WAS
AND SO. I IT IT JUST WAS A FOND
MEMORY FOR ME GETTING TO KNOW
HIM AND MEET HIM AND
RESPECTFULLY- AGREE WITH A GREAT
SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY. OF NORMAN MINETA.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAWYER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT OF I THINK THATTHE US SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE WAS
INCREDIBLY ELOQUENT IN HIS
MEMORY OF THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF
US SECRETARY MINETA AND HE AND
SENATOR SIMPSON ACTUALLY
TOGETHER VISITED THE CAMP IN
WYOMING REGULAR WAY TO CALL
ATTENTION INTO IT AND DO IT. BUT
THE SENATOR FROM FREMONT SORT OF
STRUCK THE THING THAT I WANTED
TO STRIKE BECAUSE HE WAS A HUMAN
BEING. HE ALWAYS REMEMBERED YOUR
NAME BUT HE HAD THIS INCREDIBLE
SENSE OF HUMOR. HE AND- LEON
PANETTA HAD A JOINT SOFTBALL
TEAM IN THE LEGISLATIVE WEEK AND
IT WAS CALLED. THE HOUSE OF TE
RISING PIZZA. WHICH IS VERY
LOVED AND THEY TOLD EVERYBODY
ABOUT AND THE ONE THING THAT
THOSE OF US. FEDERAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS THAT HAVE BEEN THROUGH
RACES WOULD APPRECIATE THAT HE
DID. IS LATER IN HIS CAREER HE
WAS ISSUE HE WOULD ONE OR
SEVENTY OR 80% OF THE VOTE. IN
EVERY ELECTION HE WOULD WALK ONE
PRECINCT. YOU WOULD FIND OUT
WHAT THE PRECINCT WAS OF HIS
OPPONENT. AND HE WOULD WALK
EVERY HOUSE IN THAT PRECINCT AND
THAT WAS THE ONE PRECINCT TO ANY
TOOK GREAT PLEASURE WOULD TELL
YOU ABOUT IT. HE WOULD TELL YOU
ABOUT WHERE HE WENT ON THE BLOCK
OF HIS OPPONENT AND HE JUST
ENJOYED IT AND I THINK THE THING
ABOUT IT IS IT TOO OFTEN WE
IDOLIZE SOMEBODY. FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE ACHIEVEMENTS BUT THEY
FORGET WHAT A HUMAN THEY WERE
AND WHAT HUMANITY THEY SHOWED
AND HE WAS THE BEST HARM PROUD
TO. JOIN IN ADJOURNING IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK ANY OTHER TRIBUTES
TO SEND CARSON MANADA. IN TEEN
NINE AMBIENCE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE WEEKS DEFINITE STAND OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO. A GREAT
STATESMAN. A GREAT AMERICAN HERO
AND WE ASK THAT YOU BRING THE
NAME PORT SO YOU CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY WITH A
HEAVY HEART SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW
THIS INDIVIDUAL WORK WITH HIM
FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND SOME OF
YOU JUST MAY HAVE. MET HIM A FEW
MONTHS AGO. BUT- JOE ACTOR
SCHOETTLER- JOHN ACTORS IN MY
STAFF MY LEDGE DIRECTOR AND I
THINK SOME OF YOU HAVE
COMPLIMENTED WHAT A GREAT JOB
JOHN IS DONE AND I'VE ALWAYS
COMPLIMENTED HIS DAD ON WHAT A
GREAT JOB HE'S DONE AND- IT'S
AMAZING WHEN YOU SIT DOWN AND
BREAK BREAD WITH SOMEONE AND YOU
TALK ABOUT HIS SON YOU TALK
ABOUT HIS NEW BABY GRANDCHILD OR
OF THE BEAUTIFUL WIFE THAT HIS
SON HAD JUST MARRIED INTO AND IT
JUST TOUCHES OUR HEARTS TO SEE
THAT HAPPEN IS HE HAD. THE SMILE
WHEN HE WAS ABLE TO BOAST ABOUT
JOHN GOT HIS FIRST HOME A LITTLE
FIXER UPPER BUT HE'S BEEN
WORKING ON IT WORKING ON IT NOW
IT'S HIS DREAM PALACE AND-
HAVING THE NEW BABY AND SO ON
WHAT A DREAM SO TODAY MR
PRESIDENT I RISE. A TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF JO ECKLER A LONG
TIME SACRAMENTO LOBBYIST AND
FATHER OF MY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR JOHN ACTOR. JOE PASSED
AWAY THIS IS REALLY REALLY SAD
JOE PASSED AWAY ON SATURDAY
APRIL SIXTEENTH AFTER A BRIEF
BATTLE WITH PANCREATIC CANCER.
ONLY SIXTEEN DAYS AFTER HIS
RETIREMENT. SIXTEEN DAYS AFTER
RETIREMENT BUT I WILL TELL YOU
THIS HE KNEW HE WAS GOING HE HAD
THE DIAGNOSIS HE TALKED TO THE
DOCTOR HE TALKED WITH EVERYONE.
AND HE KNEW. THAT IT WAS HIS
TIME HE WAS ABLE TO PREPARE YOU
WAS ABLE TO TALK TO HIS SONS HE
WAS ABLE TO TALK TO HIS WIFE.
AND HE HAD HIS LIFE IN ORDER
WHAT A BLESSING THAT WAS. TO BE
PREPARED LIKE THAT. HOWEVER JOE
FULFILLED HIS DREAMS OF A
LIFETIME LET'S SHARE THIS WITH
YOU- MARRYING HIS WONDERFUL
WIFE. HAVING TO OUTSTANDING SONS
AND BEING ABLE TO WATCH HIS
OLDEST SON JOHN BUYS FIRST HOME
AS I MENTIONED. AND HIS FIRST
CHILD AND MARY IS BEAUTIFUL
WONDERFUL WIFE AND JOHN IS. IS
DEEPLY DEEPLY TOUCHED. WHEN I
KNOW HE'S WATCHING IT I KNOW
HE'S HE'S PROBABLY CRYING RIGHT
NOW. BUT I SAID JOHN WE'RE GOING
TO DO THIS TOGETHER. JOE WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN PHILADELPHIA.
HE WAS A THREE SPORT ATHLETE-
THROUGHOUT HIS HIGH SCHOOL IN
ATTENDING WENT ON TO ATTEND A
MOUNT ST MARY'S UNIVERSITY IN
MARYLAND FOR HIS UNDERGRAD AFTER
GRADUATING JOB GOT A JOB WITH
THE ATLANTIC RICHFIELD OIL
COMPANY AS WE KNOW IT TODAY IS
ARCO THE GAS COMPANY THAT AND HE
WENT BACK TO SCHOOL. IT IS
ALWAYS ENCOURAGES FAMILY TO
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION SO WE
DID IT. AS A HISTORY HE
REMEMBERED. HOW IMPORTANT IS
MASTER'S DEGREE WITH GOING TO BE
IN HIS FUTURE ANYONE ON THAT.
WIDENER UNIVERSITY AFTER
COMPLETING HIS MASTER JOB MOVED
OUT HERE TO CALIFORNIA- WITH THE
ARKLE COMPANY AND DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS. JOE
REPRESENTED THE ATLANTIC
RICHFIELD COMPANY OF FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS IN MANY IN THE
CAP WITH HIM ARCO GEN. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE TO OPEN UP
HIS OWN LOBBYIST FIRM ACTOR AN
ASSOCIATE'S. CHAU LOBBIED FOR
HIS CLIENTS FROM VARIOUS
INDUSTRIES INCLUDING BIOTECH
AEROSPACE AND RETIREMENT
AGENCIES TO JUST NAME A FEW. HE
WAS COMMITTED TO ALL IT'S
CLIENTS AND RESPECTED THEM FOR
THEIR HONESTY AND THEY'RE
INTEGRITY THAT THEY RESPECTED
HIM JOE WAS A PASSIONATE GOLFER
FREQUENTLY THROUGHOUT HIS WORK
LIFE HE WAS ABLE TO ENJOY THE
GAME. AND HE WE'VE THROUGH LIFE
LOVING GOLF CLUB IN THIS FAMILY
AND GOLF HE THOUGHT HE WOULD
HAVE A CAREER IN BUT THAT WAS
THE WILDEST DREAM OF HIS LIFE.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE
GOVERNOR'S CUP AT PEBBLE BEACH
THE JOE HELP PUT TOGETHER A
BEHALF OF HIS CLIENT THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. I HAD A
GREAT TOURNAMENT IN JOE IS
EXCITED IN ITS SUCCESS MOST OF
ALL HE WAS A LOVING AND
COMMITTED HUSBAND FATHER
GRANDFATHER IN A COURT FRIEND TO
SO MANY HERE IN THE CAPITAL. HE
HAD A LARGE PRESENCE N THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY AND HE WILL BE
MISSED CHAU SURVIVES PLAYS WIDE
. THIS DISCERNED. WHO IS MARRIED
TO TATUM THE SENIOR. LEAD
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
SAMPSON ADVISORS AND- ONE OF THE
LAST BLESSINGS OF LIFE WITH
HOLDEN IS LEVINE FIRST AND ONLY
GRANDCHILD WHO IS NINE MONTHS
OLD NAME BOWIE HE WAS ABLE TO BE
WITH THE GRANDSON AND THESE LAST
FEW MONTHS. FOR THESE REASONS
AND MANY MORE I ASKED THE SENATE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JO ACTOR
AND I REGION I BOOK. CENTER
GLACIER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THAT I JOIN IN AT THE
REQUEST FROM THE CENTER FROM LOS
ANGELES BY RICHARD IN THE MEMORY
OF JAIL AFTER HE WAS A TALENTED
MEMBER OF OUR CAPITAL COMMUNITY
HE WAS INTELLIGENT HE WAS
EXPERIENCED HE WAS ALWAYS
COMPELLING AND IS ADVOCACY- WHEN
HE CAME TO MEET WTH ME AND AT
ITS HEART HE WAS A VERY GRACIOUS
PERSON. HE WOULD HANG AROUND MY
OFFICE- A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
ONE WOULD NORMALLY THINK- BUT IT
WASN'T TO ENGAGE IN SERIOUS
POLICY MATTERS AFTER THE CLOCK
STRUCK THE OUR FIVE O'CLOCK IT
WAS TO WATCH HIS SON JOHN AND
HIS PROWESS ON THE FOOSBALL
TABLE JOHN WAS A QUITE A TALENT-
IS QUITE A TALENT HIT A BALL
HARDER THAN ANYONE COULD EVER
HAVE. IMAGINED AND- JOE LOVE TO
WATCH JOHN'S PURSUITS I JUST ON
THE TWO SPOTS TO SEE FOLLOWING
HIS FOOTSTEPS UNDERSTANDING OF
OUR PUBLIC POLICY MISSION HERE
IN THE CAPITAL HE WAS A VERY
VERY PROUD FATHER SO TODAY WE
LOST A GOOD ONE REALLY REALLY
GOOD GUY AND JOE. WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED. THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I RISE TO- AT
MY APPRECIATION AND LOVE AND
RESPECT TO. FOR OUR JOURNEY
MEMORY OF JOE ACLARA HE WAS A
PROUD EAST COASTER. VERY PROUD
OF HIS PHILADELPHIA ROOTS- AND
IT WAS A PROUD DAD- I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH THEM
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND
THEN- MEDICINE ON MY CAMPAIGN
FOR THE STATE SENATE WHO WAS-
ONE OF THE FOLKS WHO HELPED GET
ME HERE AND- JUST TO NICE PEOPLE
REALLY GOOD PEOPLE AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW WIDER
COLLEGES THE- ALMA MATER OF
BILLY WHITE SHOES JOHNSON. SO
IT'S A DIVISION THREE SMALL
COLLEGE OUTSIDE OF PHILADELPHIA-
WITH ITS OWN PROUD HISTORY AND-
JOE WAS- WORE HIS PHILADELPHIA
ROOTS AND THAT WAS JUST A SOLID
SOLID AND SPECIAL HUMAN BEING
INTERESTS- DURING THE COURSE OF
A JOINING IN HIS MEMORY. SOONER
NO. MR PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE THIS I RISE
TO. ENCOURAGES THE GERMAN
MEMORY. AND I DO IT WITH GREAT
EMOTION. I KNEW THAT MAN A LOT
OF YEARS. AND SOME PEOPLE ARE
JUST A BIT STANDOFFISH IN THE
PERSONALITIES. THEY ARE ARROGANT
CONDESCENDING. THIS MAN DID NOT
ANY SUCH CHANGE WHATSOEVER.
TRULY A GENERAL TRULY ONE OF THE
TOP LOBBYIST IN MY ENTIRE CAREER
IN THIS INSTITUTION. ABSOLUTELY
TRUSTWORTHY ALWAYS ALWAYS
PREPARED. AND IF THERE WERE
PITFALLS. IT BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION. HE DIDN'T TRY
ANYTHING SNEAKY THAT A FEW DO.
DR NEVER DID. A GENTLEMAN WHO
RESPECTED THIS INSTITUTION. A
GENTLEMAN WHO THIS INSTITUTION
ON ALL WHO SERVED HERE HAVE COST
TO RESPECT. I GRIEVE HIS LOSS. I
PRAY FOR HIM AND FOR HIS FAMILY
MAY WE ADJOURN THE MEMORY. THE
ALLEGED ELECTOR THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DON'T SAYS. HEARING
SHEENA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
TO THE AQUA FAMILY A TRUE
GENTLEMAN AND A CLASS ACT HERE
NOT ONLY IN THIS BILL ANYBODY IN
THIS TOWN IS ALSO WOULD ABSENT
YOU BRING THE NAME FOR TO HE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. IF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTER
ATKINS HIS DECISION CLLR. MR
PRESIDENT THANKS SO MUCH OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION WILL BE
SCHEDULED FOR THIS THURSDAY MAY
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT
NINE AM. MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL
BE ADJOURNED AND WILL RECONVENE
AT NINE AM THURSDAY.